okay so
last week we
spent a fair bit of time
assessing
the structure of the first two stories
in genesis and i made the case that
they were stories about
the rise
of humanity into self-consciousness or
the descent of humanity into
self-consciousness depending on which
way you look at it
i should also point out that there's
been a lot of debate
among religious traditions that were
associated with those stories about
whether
the fall was an improvement or a
or catastrophe
today we're going to discuss at least to
begin with we're going to discuss
the
story of the buddha and the reason i
want to do that is twofold
well first because it's an interesting
story and second because the parallels
between it and the story in genesis are
i think they're quite remarkable
and it's not that easy to understand
exactly why they're there
so here's the story
so a long time ago
the king
got news that he was going to have a son
and an angel
visited him and said
your son is going to have one of two
destinies he's either going to become
a great and powerful
world ruler
or he's going to become
a spiritual leader
and the king thought
who was a very practical man thought
well there's no damn way my son's going
to become a spiritual leader
and so he thought
i'll make sure that he falls in love
with life
so the king
built a city before his son was born
and walled it in
and made it as beautiful as he could
possibly make it and then
decreed that within that city there
would be nothing but joy
and so
there were no people who
the only people that were allowed in
were young attractive and healthy
by express demand
and so
the buddha grew up
in that city
and fell in love with life just as his
father had
hoped
now analogy that i see there and
we'll pursue it
in more detail but the first analogy is
the
idea of a safe and segregated space like
a walled space so
paradisa paradise means walled garden
and i mentioned that eden means
well-watered place
so the idea is the same that if you want
to produce a paradise for someone you
wall in a space
and you keep everything that's not
acceptable or that might cause
existential distress let's say you keep
that out
and i would say well it's also
there's also a very interesting analog
between that and the genesis story but
also between that and the role of
parenthood in general because what you
essentially do
with young children is you
wall off a space
and you
try to make the conditions within that
space optimal
and the reason that you do that is so
that the kids your kids fall in love
with life
and so they have to be cared for
properly and attended to and cajoled in
some sense into living i mean we know
for example that
children who don't receive
proper
physical care
proper love is the right way of
describing it
don't thrive and sometimes they die and
so
it isn't enough to provide children with
food and shelter
and to protect them from the elements
they have to be interacted with
physically they have to be touched
because otherwise they don't live and
they have to be interacted with
continually
and you know that became very clear
well it was first learned
in the late 1800s when the mortality
rate
for orphans under one was 100
this guy in new york whose name
unfortunately escapes me was very
curious about why this is b was because
the children were you know at least
receiving what you might think of as the
bare minimum of care
and he
journeyed to germany he'd heard about a
nurse there
named fat anna
who had
the miraculous ability to keep children
under one alive at least in her ward the
mortality rate was much lower and so he
went there to observe what she was doing
and all she was doing was taking the
children out of their
little infant cribs and putting them
sort of on a carrier
on her hip and just walking around with
them and then she'd put that child back
in the crib and take another one out and
walk around with the child and so the
child got
you know
surface contact and a bit of stimulation
and that seemed to be enough i mean
that's pretty minimal but it was a lot
better than nothing
that was the first time
that people understood
explicitly
that
there were necessities to child care
other than
you know what you might regard as the
bare minimum
with little rats rat pups
if you take rat pups away from their
mother and
you feed them and give them enough water
and warmth they'll also die
the other thing that you have to do with
them what or what the researchers do
with them is they take a pencil
with an eraser on the end of it and then
they massage the little rat pops with
the
with the
eraser end of the pencil and that's
enough to
make them feel
loved i suppose and then they
thrive and
and there was a woman named tiffany
fields
i think this work was originally done by
yak panksep the massage work with the
rat pups
and there's a woman named tiffany field
who started
a program in florida where they massaged
premature infants who were in the
incubators
for i believe it was three times a day
for 10 minutes
and what happens with children these are
premature infants generally who are in
incubators what generally happens to
them is first of all they lose weight
and that's really not good because
children infants near birth are supposed
to be packing on a lot of weight
so any loss is not only the loss but
also
a decrease from the gain and so you know
it it raises their mortality rate
substantially and what fields and her
researchers found that
was that three minutes of three sessions
of massage for 10 minutes a day
would
the babies who were
given that would gain weight as fast as
children who were still
in the womb
and that you could detect positive
physiological psychological
and so forth emotional benefits six
months later which is a very long time
in the in the life of an infant
so
so that's all to say that you know the
role of parents is to
set up a protective
wall for all intents and purposes around
their children so that they're not
subjected to
you know the unabated harshness of life
and then to
cajole them into
living and thriving
now we need to know that children have a
play circuit that's separate so they
need to play
and the touch circuit seems to be
mediated by all opiates
and so one of the consequences of that
is that if a child has scraped his or
her knee and comes running up to you and
says fix it and you give them a hug and
pat them
that fixes it because the the touch is
actually analgesic
and so it's also a useful thing to know
if you're ever dealing with someone
who's grieving because
there's not much you can do about grief
from our
cognitive perspective you know i mean
you can help allay people's guilt
if they're
suffering from undue guilt about
the circumstances
but
if they're grieving they're in pain
because grief is a pain response
technically speaking you can alleviate
it with opiates you can also alleviate
it with antidepressants to some degree
which is also something else worth
knowing because sometimes you'll see
someone who's so deep in grief that
they're going to hurt themselves because
of it you know it's traumatizing it'll
produce brain damage it'll really do
them in and that's just not helpful
so it's useful to know that
antidepressants can ameliorate that
you know and you might say well people
still have to go through a natural
grieving process it's like
well actually the grieving process is
the pain
that the healing process is the
rebuilding of a life outside of the
person who say who died
and that takes time and effort and the
antidepressant isn't going to interfere
with that so it's not self-evident that
people have to suffer themselves
three-quarters to death in order to
begin the healing process post grief
but touch is also very
helpful directly and so one of the
things i recommend to my clients who are
grieving is that they go get massages
because
it's comforting you know that direct
human to human contact actually has a
anti-grief effect
so
all right so anyways the buddha grows up
in this beautiful
attractive safe place
but of course
he be he develops into adolescence and
that makes him curious and so he notices
more and more consciously the existence
of the walls and starts to wonder what's
outside
and so
he starts to plague his father
he wants to go out and he wants to go
out and he wants to go out and of course
that's a developmental story too because
that's exactly what happens with
children right is that once they hit
oh it's probably 11 something like that
they're i mean even at four their
orientation starts to move away from the
parental unit
out to the social community so
a child should be socialized
with regards to his or her ability to
interact with non-familial
with people who aren't part of the
family between the ages of two and four
so at two a child is still pretty
egocentric it's hard for them to play
with other children they can play beside
them and you know they can play to some
degree two-year-olds are actually often
quite good at playing with babies which
is quite interesting you know it seems
to be part of their inbuilt capacity you
know
but
between two and four they have to learn
complicated lessons like how to share
that's a tough one
and
because it kind of you know it involves
taking the place of the other person to
some degree but it also involves
comprehending the future you know the
idea that
if you lend something out someone else
can play with it and you'll get it back
and that'll be okay and that's a
complicated one and then they also have
to learn how to negotiate a script which
is a ridiculously important thing to
learn right so
they can either do that
formally when they play say a board game
that has rules a simple board game or a
game like marbles that actually has
rules
to which they have to subordinate
themselves so basically what's happening
is they're moving from a egocentric
perspective where they're only playing
their own game under the guys you know
under the control of their own
motivational
structures
to playing a game that two people or
more can join into under the rubric of a
higher order system of of rules and
goals so what they're basically doing is
learning to subordinate
their motor individual motivational
states to a state of being that allows
multiple people to integrate their
motivational and emotional states across
time it's very very sophisticated
it's very complicated thing to learn how
to do and then of course they also learn
how to do
how to pretend play
and pretend play is far more important
than people
generally realize
the typical pretend script will be
there's a number of kids you know two or
more
and they're going to play
they're going to have a little dramatic
episode like maybe they're going to play
house or
and then they're all assigned roles
that's all from mutual agreement and
then the kids basically negotiate what
the script is going to be and then they
play it out it's it's a form of thinking
right it's a it's a form of
embodied thinking but what's really
interesting about it is that
they have to
agree on the structure of the game and
the rules well when you negotiate with
adults for the rest of your life
especially in an intimate relationship
that's exactly what you're going to do
if you're negotiating properly it's like
okay what do we want to have happen here
in this space that we share and how are
we going to conduct ourselves mutually
so that occurs and people are really
really not good at that you know but it
is an extended form of playing and
if the relationship is going well then
there's all there's an element of play
in it because that's one of the things
that makes it
enjoyable instead of just you know
tyranny and necessity
so
well
so the child starts to move out into the
world but that increases you know the
the voyage length in some sense
increases because the other thing
children do and this is often but not
always with their mothers
they use her as
a marker of defined territory i think
that's the easiest way to think of it
and then they scoot out from that marker
and do some exploring until they get
tired or overwhelmed then they come back
and they get comforted and padded and
you know put back into a routine and
then they're all put back together and
then they go out next time a little bit
farther and they run back and so a big
chunk of what you're doing as a parent
is not so much 24 7 monitoring as
making yourself available as a resource
when the child deems that necessary so
that's part of why it's useful to be
around well i mean if you're a parent
your place can be taken by another adult
but that's only true really
if the child knows the adult like
children can make multiple
parent-like bonds
but one thing they hate is having their
primary caregiver changed because that
the primary caregivers their whole world
so when you change that on them you just
flip them upside down and so they can
tolerate
multiple caregivers
but they have a really rough time
tolerating transitions in child
in in in caregivers especially the
younger they are the worse that is
so
well then you know as the child
progresses towards adolescence then
there's another burst of
independence seeking activity pretty
much at puberty for obvious reasons
and
you know that's when
the child is going to turn their
attention
almost entirely to fitting into the
social world and so that's a form of
apprenticeship we talked about that
earlier in class that
so you can think the child goes from
dependence
to
like dependence on the familial
structure
to interdependence with other children
and and then that sort of would
transform into
enculturation and the development of an
idea of a cultural identity
and then perhaps there's a stage past
that where
morality is defined as
something outside of pure cultural
identification and that would be
something more akin to in individuation
or
and that's the stage
at which
and this is a piagetian idea the person
recognizes themselves as a creator and
modifier of rules as well as a
follower
and adherent of rules
and you can even think to some degree
that the divide between conservative and
liberal is a divide of that sort now the
mapping isn't precise
but the conservatives tend to be low in
openness and high in conscientiousness
and so they're not that interested in
transformation they're interested in
maintaining the rules of the game and
doing well within that set of rules
and the liberals position is well
sometimes the rules themselves need to
be altered and so
you can't just blindly accept the game
and follow it you have to be willing to
adjust it when it's necessary so there's
a constant tension between those two
positions that's somewhat like the
tension between
osiris and horus
you know if it's all conservative then
things staltify and that's not good
because
the world changes and if your
static cultural system doesn't change
then it falls by the wayside
but the conservatives would say well
don't be changing more things than you
have to because all you do is invite
chaos in and so you could say in some
sense that
there's a pet on both sides of the
political continuum and the pit on the
conservative side is stultification
and the pit on the liberal side is
chaos so
the whole polity is trying to
continually maneuver between chaos and
order
and the way you do that isn't by having
the liberals or the conservatives win
the way you do that is by having the
liberals and conservatives talk
and as soon as they can't talk then
there's trouble
because they both stand for a principle
that can't be abandoned
so and because
the balance between chaos and order
shifts with time as the environment
shifts
awake and aware people have to
continually negotiate to determine
exactly where that line is because it's
not in the same place all the time
so
and that's not going so well at the
moment especially in the us you know and
that's not good and who knows what'll
come of it but it's definitely not good
so
all right so that by the time you know a
child is adolescent then there's a fair
bit of impetus to move out into the
world beyond the confines of the
familial structure
if that doesn't happen
then
generally you could infer that
the child has not had its is either the
child is quite dependent in terms of its
fundamental temperament or that its
independence has not been properly
fostered by the parents
now
so there's there's there was literature
now and i haven't looked into this for
it's probably 20 years now but there was
literature that i was aware of when i
was doing research on drug and alcohol
abuse
that
there were two populations at risk if
you look at how children adolescents use
drug and alcohol drugs and alcohol in
junior high in high school there were
two populations at risk
one population was those who
experimented with everything and used
everything to an excess and all you can
you it doesn't take much description to
understand where that might lead to
antisocial behavior and and whatever
damage you might accrue by you know
formulating your socialization around
alcohol for example but the other group
that was in trouble was those kids who
never experimented
and so
it was you've got two kinds of
pathologies there and one pathology was
a chaos pathology basically and the
other one was an order pathology and the
kids in the middle were ones who would
experimented to some degree you know
because partly what
adolescents are doing is poking the
social world the world of law really to
see
where its contours are you know because
part of their question is well
is it necessary for me to follow these
rules and
you can't be told that
you have to
experiment and see
what the necessity is for the rule
following and that means that your
parents have to allow you at least in
principle
there's a certain amount of freedom that
you need to be allowed
or at least that's one way of looking at
it
so
there's at least some freedom that you
have to be allowed if the goal of
parenting is the production of someone
who's
capable of taking care of themselves
now you know it isn't obvious that
that's always the goal of parenting
because some cultures are more
interdependent and there's no
necessary presumption on the part of the
parents that the person is going to
live
the person is going to have to be
capable of living in a fully independent
existence but
okay so what happens is
the king's son gets curious
now at this point he also has a a
retainer a guy who is with him all the
time who's teaching him things but
the gods had got wind of the father's
plan and decided that they weren't going
to make things as simple as he wanted
them to be so
the retainer is an agent of the gods
and so and he's always whispering in the
in the son's ear well anyways
buddha the future buddha gets
curious and decides i'm going out i'm
going out there and so his father
realizes at some point that there's just
no way that he's going to be able to get
be kept inside
so he pulls a fast one
it goes out
to the city surrounding the walled city
to the area surrounding the walled city
and he chases away all the homeless
people and he
chases away all the elderly people and
he chases away all the sick people and
he has everybody spruce everything up so
that it's in perfect shape and then he
lines the streets that the buddha's
carriage is going to go through with the
most attractive people he can find all
cheering
and so
one day they open the gates and the
buddha rides out in his in his chariot
his cart and his his retainer is behind
him and you know they go down the
streets and the buddha's thinking this
is just a fine old day and then
someone who's ill wanders out onto the
road in front of him
and he's looking pretty rough this guy
is very sick
and it's evident just by looking at him
that things are not going well
and you know the buddha stops his
chariot and the shock watching this
person you know stumble across the road
and he asks his retainer
what the hell is going on here and the
retainer says
well you know this this person is ill
and
he's not something has gone wrong with
him he's not functioning well and
illness is the lot of mankind and it
happens to everyone and so the buddha is
not very happy about that piece of
information and
bang he goes back into the
walled city
and that's just like
he's running back to his mother roughly
speaking it's the same idea right it's
it's a piece of information he's just
been
offered an anomalous piece of
information that's sufficient to shatter
the structure of some of his his his
value
hierarchy wow back he goes you know it
takes him like six months to digest that
piece of information but he manages it
and then his curiosity starts to grow
again
and so he starts harassing his father
again about going outside again so the
father tries to pull the same trick but
he's extra careful this time he makes
sure all the sick people are rounded up
and put somewhere where no one's going
to see them and he lines the streets
again and the buddha goes out and it's a
beautiful day and
the streets are lined with cheering
people and all of a sudden
the gods are involved in this
they're playing tricks on the father so
they're the random that's the random
uncontrollable element you know and i
would say that's roughly equivalent to
the snake in the garden of eden so it's
the buddha's curiosity that drives him
out you know even though his father
tells him that is set it up so that he
shouldn't go and when he goes out there
the anomalous thing occurs and fractures
him
so he goes out well this time someone
who's really aged hobbles out into the
road you know all gray and wrinkled and
bent over and not moving very well and
the buddha is shocked out of his mind
again and he says to this retainer
what's
what's up with this
and his retainer says look you know how
you've you know gone from small to
larger and you know how you grow well
people continue to do that but at some
point they start to age and
things don't go so well in events and
and that's the law of mankind and so
the buddha is like that's enough fun for
one day and bang he goes back into the
walled city and this time he stays
inside for a whole year it's just like
the rats who go out there and see that
cat you know and then go back to their
borough and scream for two weeks it's
exactly the same idea
and so fine a year later he's more or
less
put himself back together and he decides
to go out again and his father
pulls exactly the same trick for exactly
the same reasons
but this time the buddha encounters a
funeral procession and he can see the
body
and it's lying there still and cold and
everyone is weeping and dressed in black
and it's a terrible situation and the
buddha asked his retainer
what's up with this and his retainer
says well you know you saw someone who
was sick and you saw someone who was old
and like the the worst case scenario for
both of those is death and the buddha
says well what's that and the retainer
explains to him as best he can
well this time this is such a shock that
he can't even go back to the
to the wall
garden so to speak
so his father
so this is the sort of shock that
completely collapses his belief in his
say infantile paradise it's the death
idea then it's the same idea that comes
up in genesis right is that when adam
and eve
are driven by their curiosity to
interact with this snake-like
entity you know their realization is one
of death and that blows paradise
permanently they don't go back in fact
god makes it impossible for them to go
back which is a variation in the
buddhist story because
buddha himself decides that he's not
going back
well his father has one more trick up
his sleeve
so
he calls on the most attractive women in
the kingdom to go into a forest nearby
and to disrobe and to dance erotically
and to attract and you know to bring the
buddha there to attract him back into
life to make him
feel that the pleasures of living are
sufficient so that this unfortunate
incident can be put behind him but
when he goes into the forest all he can
think about is the transformation of
flesh into decay and death and that's
that
done he can't go home again
and that's what starts his journey and
so the next thing the buddha does
is
he becomes an adept at all sorts of
different disciplinary traditions
you know so he becomes an ascetic and he
starves himself so thoroughly that you
know you can see a single grain of rice
passed down his throat and he
you know so he puts himself through
martial arts traditions and ascetic
traditions and all sorts of religious
traditions trying to
in some sense put himself back together
so the idea is that
his fundamental
and naive
non-self-conscious early belief system
is fractured completely by his discovery
of sickness old age and death
and then
as a fractured entity he then submits
himself
to various forms of discipline trying to
reconstitute himself
none of that really succeeds
and then the story ends with him going
under a tree the bow tree and adopting
that classic buddha pose and
trying to attain enlightenment
enlightenment through meditation and
self-examination which he actually
manages to do and then he attains
enlightenment and is in a state of
nirvana
but decides that he can't
he he decides that it's immoral
to stay in that
mode of being
unless everybody can be there so he
leaves nirvana which in some sense is
his final temptation he leaves nirvana
and then goes out and starts to teach
and so that's the story of the buddha
so
now you know the off the most obscure
part of that is what happens underneath
the bow tree
you know now
there's an there's a
there's also an analog between that and
what happens in the
the whole
what would you call it narrative of
christianity because what happens with
christ is that
his
identity with god is fundamentally
manifested when he ends up on a tree
it's different right because there's a
crucifixion on a tree and it is regarded
as a tree
in the
what would you call it
in the mythological tradition so there's
an idea
in
symbolic christianity
that
christ is crucified
on
on this on the same tree
where adam discovered that he was going
to die
and there's a reason for that like
there's a reason for that and the reason
fundamentally is is that
both genesis and the story of the buddha
make the proposition that it's this it's
the it's the it's the
uh ultimate extension of
self-consciousness
that
devastates people existentially it's the
discovery of death let's say but it's
not just that it's it's it's
vulnerability per se it's not just death
because there are worse things than
death
and
that it's that discovery of ultimate
vulnerability that turns people into the
creatures that they are and that one
response to that is to build culture
which is exactly what happens with the
buddha he traverses multiple cultures
right becoming a master of many specific
subcultures and then what happens in the
old testament is that after the fall and
after the story of adam and eve and
after the story of noah those are all
the really before the flood stories
those are the really ancient stories
then you fall into history and you have
the continual creation and destruction
of the
of the israelite states
and
you know then there's a break in some
sense between judaism and christianity
and it's an interesting break
you know i'm no expert in judaism but i
i
i think i've got this basically right
is that
the
christians make a decision that whatever
christ represented was the solution to
the problem not only of
emergent self-consciousness but also
for the insufficiency of history
because remember you get an empire
building and collapsing and an empire
building and collapsing and
you know one answer to that is
a bigger and better empire
and another answer is there's something
wrong with the idea of empire as a
solution to the initial problem
and i would say that the jews and the
christians basically split on that
proposition and so that's partly why
i mean
from the from the
position of judaism there may still be a
messiah but but that person is not
someone who's yet appeared
and then there's another proposition
which is
the state itself is redemptive
and that's played out at least in part
in israel where the state is viewed as
redemptive that things will go well for
the jewish people if and only if they
can establish a state
now a skeptic would say yeah but all the
things that the state was supposed to
keep out start cropping up inside
and i think that you have to be rather
blind not to see that that's happened to
a large degree in israel i mean one of
the things that's happened forget about
the palestinians and the arabs for the
time being but even with in judaism
itself there's a major fracture between
the more orthodox jews the ones who are
very very very conservative in their
beliefs and and habits and the more
secular you know westernized jews and
it's it's some sense it's the
distinction between right wing and left
wing but that's been a you know a very
very divisive divisive
um battle within israel
and
what it shows in part is that you
just because you establish a state
doesn't mean you can assume that the
kind of homogeneity that will eliminate
conflict will then reign within that
state
because people within the state can
fragment into different groups just like
states themselves can be representative
of other groups
now
the
if you look at the symbolic
meaning i think or the psychological
meaning of christianity the idea is that
the answer to the pathology of the state
is the constant renewal of the
individual and so
that that falls into alignment with the
idea of death and rebirth you know so if
the problem is
the balance between chaos and order
both at the state level and the and the
individual level you might say well
where
where should action take place in order
to redeem the state and the i would say
that the central western idea and this
is something that emerged out of
christianity was that the way to
transform the state is through the
transformation of the individual so
rather than the other way around which
is you transform the state and hope all
the individuals follow we tried that for
example in the soviet union because you
could say that
the communist experiment was precisely
the attempt to modify the state so that
the individuals would follow
now
i've been reading
i just bought a new book
a very cheerful book called the black
book of communism
and it was published in france in 1999
and the fact that it was published in
france is particularly interesting
because of all the european countries
with the possible exception of italy
communists had the largest sway over
especially intellectual life
and so i would say that the
life of intellectuals in france after
world war ii was overwhelmingly
radically left weight and and not just
of the socialist type but of the
communist type i mean both both italy
and france had communist parties
and the
french intellectuals including people
like sartre
were
sergeant never did belong to the
communist party but he was a supporter
of the communist party and all the
people
all the french thinkers that are
worshiped so to speak in universities
today were all radical left-wingers who
were involved in the student riots in
and their beliefs were
can't amount to communistic
and that's not a good thing so this book
was written by people many of whom were
former french intellectual communists it
was written in 1999 and i read the
forward and two of the chapters last
night
and
the first thing that the person who
wrote the forward claims is that it
wasn't possible to do a real analysis of
the historical significance of communism
until 1999 until basically the end of
the century because
what the communists had done was so
obscure and so secret that there was no
way to discover it and i thought that's
complete rubbish because
by 1945
or thereabouts george orwell was already
writing animal farm
and
and he wrote
1984 in 1948 he just reversed the last
letters and he knew perfectly well what
was happening in the communist countries
and so if your eyes were open i would
say by 1935 you could tell because
that's was more or less in the midst of
the ukrainian famine which killed some
four to six million people
so
so anyways so
there was the 30s then things were
complicated by the fact of the second
world war because
well
first of all the radical left was
fighting against fascism say in spain to
begin with and lots of european and
american intellectuals went to spain to
fight against franco and ended up on the
side roughly speaking of the communists
so that complicated things because the
frankel
faction was definitely bad news so it
was like a prototype of world war ii
because franco was a fascist he ruled
until
wasn't very long ago well
you know compared to world war ii i
think it was maybe 1980 19 somewhere
around 1980 he finally died in fred and
spain
transformed itself back into a democracy
and i went to spain
just before that and it was
it was an unbelievably poor country
you could stay in spain in the middle of
madrid for a dollar fifty a night so so
that would be probably equivalent to
about five dollars now and that got you
a private room with a shower and
breakfast
and wine there was cheaper than water it
was about 75 cents a bottle which is
something i remember very fondly
but you know its economy was entirely
devastated so
in the spanish civil war the left wing
rose up against the fascists essentially
and that was a precursor to world war ii
and then when world war ii emerged even
though stalin had made a number of pacts
with hitler you know the russians joined
the west as an ally and so for a while
there it was counterproductive in some
sense to
to be criticizing the
the soviet union too intently because
there was something you know that needed
to be taken care of first so there's
some excuse for
focusing on the nazi horror first and
then
and only then focusing on what happened
in the communist countries but still by
the end of world war ii anybody who
wanted to know could know
and what that basically meant was that a
massive swath of the western intel
intelligentsia put their damn heads in
the sand and protected regimes that were
so pathological that they defied
description
so
there there are relatively new figures
in this black book of communism
that describe deaths
so
you can attribute 25 million deaths
directly to the nazi oppression
and 100 million to communism
so the bulk of that was the soviet union
where it's 20 to 35 million
it's an estimated 60 million and i
should also say something about
solzhenitsyn so the french
intellectuals who were behind the
publication of this book which by the
way was a hit in france it was a
bestseller and very very controversial
partly because people said well if you
criticize the left then you you know the
radical left then you give carte blanche
to the radical right and of course the
radical right has become an emergent
phenomena well
you're gonna watch it play out because
here it comes you know sweden all the
scandinavian countries germany holland
france the right-wing parties are coming
back and that's not going to stop and of
course the same thing is happening in
the united states with trump
so
the left radical left-wingers in france
were saying well i don't pick on the
communists even historically because
that'll validate the claims of the
radical right-wingers which i think is
an
entirely appalling and pathetic argument
you know it's like saying don't
criticize the nazis because that'll
encourage the communists it's just not
an acceptable way of comporting yourself
and so
but but anyways
it was
not
politically correct shall we say to
criticize the communists especially in
france but that turned around to some
degree by 1999 but i should also say
that
in it was 1974 that solzhenitsyn wrote
his book the gulag archipelago and if
you wanted to know what was happening in
the soviet union all you had to do was
read that book like it's a hell of a
book it's 27 i think it's 2700 pages
long and it's very small type and it's
it's one intense piece of work you know
you don't read that as bedtime reading
because it's it's so
draw-droppingly appalling that it's like
permanently traumatizing but if you
wanted to know
you could have known in 1974 and
more to the point you could have known
in 1945 you could have known in 1930 but
the western intelligencia
basically covered up the communist
pathology i would say for something on
the order of 70 years and
there's been no reckoning with that
whatsoever in america in in european
higher institutions of learning and so
one of the things i still see and i see
this because i talk about this quite a
bit in my psychology 230 classes that
virtually every student knows about the
holocaust and and for a good reason
but
very very few people know what happened
in soviet in the soviet union or
certainly in china where the french
estimates are now 65 million people
right
so and you know that's so opaque to us
you know i know some things about this
but not very much i mean i know that you
could certainly make the claim that mao
was the greatest monster who ever lived
you know even though he's still a
revered figure in china which is an
appalling figure you know an appalling
thing
all in itself
now i don't know if you guys noticed
this morning he probably didn't but one
of the things that was trending on
facebook was kim young ills i think
that's his name
i get all those
horrible
wretched
dictators confused because they all look
the same and have the same
general satanic essence
they basically
like back in the i think it was in the
80s but it might have been in the 90s
three million or so north koreans
starved to death
and
what's his name the dictator
um
came out and announced today to his
north korean population that they're
going to have to go back and he said
this to sucking roots to survive
and not only that he's demanding that
every family in the capital donate two
pounds of rice a month to the state
warehouses so you can see where
communist economics gets you it's the
warehouses that are supposed to be
distributing the food to the starving
people that are now
tyrannizing them into donating what they
don't even have to the state warehouses
and so you know that's the last bastion
of stalinism slash maoism and the
chinese of course still support north
korea even though it is there's plenty
of pathological countries on the face of
the planet but you know you have to give
either the gold or the silver medal to
north korea
you know where no one has enough to eat
except a tiny proportion of
you know
unbelievably corrupt aristocracy right
at the top
and you know
he's treated as if he's a divinity he is
a kind of divinity but not the positive
kind so
all right so
back to
back to uh
so the idea there is you know
if you're trying to figure out how to
rectify the plight of humanity
that's that's a good way of
conceptualizing the problem so the
plight is laid out both in the story of
the buddha and in the stories that we
covered last week in genesis it's very
straightforward people woke up and
noticed that they were going to die
it's more complicated than that but it's
it's because it's not just depth it's
it's vulnerability and all fronts so you
could say death insanity and social
judgment
so death illness insanity and social
judgment that's
what being self-conscious means to
people and i would say the two largest
class of fears go along with the
mythological categories that we've been
discussing because people are most
afraid of the terrible mother and the
dragon so to speak that's chaos that's
death and the other thing they're most
afraid of is tyrannical judgment
and you know those things are
intertangled because of course if you're
rejected by your culture and forced to
the bottom of the hierarchy the
probability that you're going to
confront a chaotic death radically
increases so you know you can't really
separate out rejection from
from chaos
but those are deaf and you see this with
people of anxiety disorders they're
almost always afraid of two categories
of things one is
death and the illness and the other is
social judgment so if you take the
typical agrophobic her because she it's
usually she
her biggest fear is that she's going to
have a heart attack on a subway and make
a fool of herself while she dies
and you know because that's well it's
like the ultimate nightmare in some
sense it is it is in fact the ultimate
nightmare
now the problem with the story of the
buddha in part is that
the ending the enlightenment element is
vague it isn't clear what happens there
now
i have a suspicion that that story grew
out of a far older tradition which was
the shamanic tradition
and one of the things that's
characteristic of the shamanic tradition
is that
the shaman usually they take some kind
of psychoactive drug in the siberia
which is where shamanism was most widely
spread and most established
the drug was amanita muscaria which is a
particular kind of mushroom
it's the red mushroom with the white
caps on it white white dots on it that
you see in fairy tales all the time and
there's a reason for that
and
and you know a poll that that would
occupy that the connection between earth
and heaven was often a central feature
of a shamanic ritual and one of the
things that was happening with the
shaman is that when they took the
psychoactive drug they would climb the
pole
that represented the connection between
earth and heaven and they would go up
into the domain of the gods which is
roughly equivalent to the idea of buddha
reaching nirvana and so there's a
there's an uncharted
relationship between the most archaic
human religions which were virtually
undoubtedly grounded in the use of very
powerful psychoactive chemicals and the
buddhist tradition and i think part of
the reason that the vagueness is there
is because
the direct connection between the
what would you call it
the theological use of transformative
substances and the doctrine per se is
not being well specified i mean now you
see the same thing in
in in south america the drug there is
usually ayahuasca which is chemically
actually
amanita muscaria is different chemically
from ayahuasca ayahuasca is very much
like psilocybin
and like lsd it has the same ringed
molecular structure but of course when
the when the amazonian shaman take
ayahuasca they also
communicate with the ancestors and the
gods
and that's a classic shamanic
pathway first communion with the
ancestors then communion with the gods
and it's actually based on the direct
experience of the people who are
putting themselves into this ceremony
so
there's also some very interesting
connections historically between
christianity and the use likely of
psilocybin mushrooms so there was a very
weird book written in 1968 or
thereabouts called the magic mushroom
the sacred mushroom and the cross i
think that's the name of it
where it was a linguist who identified
linguistic patterns between the
theological claims of christianity and
the language used to describe mushrooms
and their effect now that book came out
sort of at the height of the hippie
revolution and even though it was a
serious book it was sort of shunted off
into the hippies wrote this category
although it's not a hippie book at all
i've read it a couple of times i have no
idea what to make of the book because
because it's based on linguistics it's
far outside my range of
of competence to evaluate but you
certainly can't brush it off lightly and
since then there's been all sorts of
evidence emerged that the use of
mushrooms might have been central to it
to early christianity
anyways
the fundamental split
you could say that
i think this is a reasonable way to look
at it too is that
once the basic problem that faces
humanity is laid out rather clearly and
so we'll say that's the problem of a
painful self-consciousness and knowledge
of finitude which is a major problem
right i mean the terror management
people
the social psychologists who are terror
management uh theorists basically say
that that's rendered people permanently
pathological and that they have to use
illusion in order to defend themselves
against that and freud basically made
the same argument
when he was criticizing classical
religion he basically said well
people are using religious nonsense
roughly speaking as a way of shielding
themselves against their fear of death
because they're too immature to be able
to tolerate the reality you know and
it's it's an interesting criticism and i
found it quite compelling for quite a
long time
and i do think that people hide in their
belief systems but i think one of the
basic shortcomings of the freudian idea
is that it doesn't really account for
why
people would invent the idea of hell for
example because that doesn't really seem
to be a lot more comforting than the
idea of death in fact it's a lot worse
it's like not only you die but you die
permanently or you die forever
continually in the most painful possible
ways i can't really see that as a
why bother with that if it's an illusion
you could say well it's just to make the
illusion more believable but you know
once you have to throw two conspiracies
together to account for a phenomenon i
think your
your the onus of proof is definitely on
you know
so okay so then the question is
well what's the
what's the cure for the pathology the
self-conscious pathology and i could say
i could say well there's two answers to
that and one is
the building of a state
you know and and that's
obviously that's of some utility because
the terror management people tend to
think of
culture as psychological and as a
defense mechanism against the fear of
death but that's
it's it's an overly psychological
explanation because obviously one of the
things that culture does as well as
protecting you from the fear of death is
actually protect you from death you know
in our culture does everything it can
not only
to protect you from death
but also to protect you from any
exposure to death you know part of the
reason and this is something the 60s
hippies jumped up and down about two
part of the reason that we have
psychiatric nomenclature and an entire
psychiatric system is to take people who
are so crazy that they're disturbing off
the street so that they don't
you know wreak existential havoc on the
people who are outside you know and you
can debate about whether or not that's
appropriate but you know it's definitely
the case that it's much more difficult
to walk down the street if there's very
many people who are overtly damaged and
expressive about it on that street and
you can say well they have a right to be
there and you can say well the public
has a right to protect itself and
obviously both those claims are valid
and there's you know the right way
through it is a consequence of dialogue
but it's still nonetheless the case that
we're almost never exposed to
extreme old age we're never exposed to
death and we're almost never exposed to
you know insanity and a physical illness
unless you go into a hospital or a place
like that
so
one answer to the problem that faces
mankind is the state has the answer
and the other well let's and then we can
examine that but the problem with that
seems to be that the state
can split into something that's very
pathological and something that isn't
those are the archetypal elements of the
state and then you could make a case
that when the state is fully
pathological it's actually worse than
the original problem
so then the question becomes okay well
the state has utility what you do to
stop it from becoming corrupt that's the
real question as far as i can tell
and so
i would say the egyptians partially
solved that problem when they started to
build their mythology of horus and
osiris because they basically said well
there's two principles that have to be
at work in order
not only in order to maintain the state
and so we'll say against isis and the
forces of the underworld
isis being the goddess of the underworld
not the new isis it's pretty damn funny
that that's their initials you know
so
the state's a necessity but it has to be
updated as a consequence of the careful
action of the
citizen represented you know by the
attention of the citizen represented by
horus now there are many critiques of
christianity
i would say most of these come on the
atheistic end of things who make
the point that if you take the
mythologies of horus
and the mythologies of christ and you
line them up side by side they're
virtually the same so many of the
mythological elements of
christ's because he's you know half say
mythological and half historical
although the evidence for his historical
existence is very very thin
but it's heavily mythologized and a lot
of the mythology that was used to
represent christ was just taken
completely from the mythology of horus
and so the atheistic
wing of
criticism critics of christianity say
well obviously that means that
christianity is false because its
central figure was just granted the
attributes of
the previous
egyptian
deity but
well
but i think that that criticism is
fundamentally beside the point in in the
most important of ways because
the ideas of what characterized horus
emerged as a consequence of a lengthy i
would say evolutionary process to define
what constituted the central redeemer of
the state roughly speaking and then that
was just translated onto
christ and that
that is just a continuation of the
religious dream in a sense it's not
indication that there's something
fundamentally fraudulent about
christianity
i mean
unless you think that christianity is
based on the kind of history that
empirical historic historians regard as
history that's not the only kind of
history
so
all right so
then i want to i want to talk about
something else in relationship to that
so
and this is sort of
in some sense this is the last part of
the course which is good given that
we're coming to the end
when i was working on these ideas i laid
out the logic that that you just that i
just described to you you know that
mankind has a fundamental existential
problem i don't think that's a
particularly radical claim that's made
that claim is made by all sorts of
schools of thought not least the
existentialists
but i would say that that problem was
already put very clearly in our most
ancient religious writings
so it's not a new idea it's a very very
old idea
and
then out of that emerged the idea that
the state would emerge as a
medication for that fundamental
pathology and you see that in genesis
right away because as soon as adam and
eve have their eyes open they put on fig
leaves so the first thing they do is
turn
fig leaf is an emblem of culture you
know it's clothing and so clothing is
certainly one of the things that
distinguishes us from animals and so the
idea that we could build structures that
would protect ourselves
well that's what we do and they work but
they don't necessarily solve the
fundamental problem
or at least they don't solve it
permanently and they lead to another set
of problems and the other set of
problems is the pathology of the state
and so the state then instead of
becoming
a defense a genuine defense or let's
even say an adaptation to our
vulnerability starts to become an
exploiter of our vulnerability
and i would say that
you know
there are roots so the communist idea
was a utopian ideal
and
the idea was that
the idea was that the pathology that
characterized human beings could be laid
at the feet of the state
there was no
notion whatsoever that part of the
pathology of being human is an inbuilt
part of being human now that's kind of
an original sin claim in some sense is
that we could heap all the culture we
want on you it's not going to solve your
problem
now
so the marxist utopian idea had its
roots in certain strains of christian
utopian thinking
so because it was saint thomas moore who
wrote the first book on utopia and so
you know christianity in some sense
influenced the utopian element of
marxism but it was the marxists in
particular who decided that the reason
that human beings had problems was
because of the organization of the state
now
so that and then there was a conclusion
from that and the conclusion was well if
you just got rid of the apparent
pathology of the state then people would
enter into a utopian mode of being and
so what are the pathologies of the state
well they're still the things that
radical egalitarians
are opposed to hierarchical structure
differential uh distribution of
resources
that's pretty much
you know private ownership is part of
that but you know i would say that
that's more like an integrally
that's tied integrally within the first
two problems and so then the marxist
idea was basically on the one hand
eradicate prior private property
distribute resources equally eliminate
the distinctions between the classes
because they thought of classes as the
fundamental dividing
you know categories of people not race
like the nazis but class
and
then you'd usher in a an endless utopia
well you know stated like that it just
sounds stupid
and you know because i i
maybe that's too harsh but i don't
really think it is
in in the late
1800s he knew all this was coming he
absolutely knew this was coming
and god only knows how he knew it i mean
yoon would say he was very much in touch
with the collective unconscious and you
could think of the collective
unconscious in some senses like imagine
that you have a system of ideas you know
that you're are that you articulate and
you are aware of but they rest on a
dream
you know which is the place where the
ideas are coming from but also like the
matrix out of which the ideas emerge
it's a dream like fantasy and it's
something that's more or less shared by
everyone and you could be farther away
or closer to that underlying dream like
structure and the more artistic you are
the more open i would say the closer you
are to that dreamlike structure well
dostoevsky was immersed right inside it
and i think that was partly because he
was
epileptic so because epileptics have
transcendent experiences often and and
suffer from an uh overwhelming
intensification of emotions and so that
did something to dostoevsky that sort of
put him into a different category that's
what it looks like to me but anyways he
knew this was coming in in his book the
devil's aptly named or the possessed he
says this is what's wrong with russia
here's what's happened as a consequence
of our belief system falling apart
here's the sort of person who is
destined to emerge and this is what's
going to happen it's exactly right
so
and at the same time dostoevsky was
thinking this through and he and this he
did most clearly in the book notes from
underground which i would highly
recommend that you read because it's
very short it's very interesting and
it's unutterably brilliant
and the reason it's brilliant is because
dostoevsky's main character in the book
you know who's partly informed by
autobiographical experience is a failed
civil servant
who is a nobody and who is super
resentful and he's a coward he's angry
resentful and cowardly but he's very
very smart and of course he's very proud
about the fact that he's smart because
that's pretty much what he has to cling
on to he doesn't have a family he
doesn't have anything else
but
so he's an appalling person you could
say he's caught in the underworld but
what's interesting is that
being caught in the underworld in that
chaos
he doesn't degenerate right into someone
who's nihilistic or totalitarian he kind
of tolerates the tension and there's
certain things that emerge for for him
as potential truths and so one of the
things he says was that he sort of toyed
with the idea of utopia
and he talks about
he talks about the
palace of crystal and so in the palace
of crystal
it's a perfect future utopia
and everyone is provided with what they
need and dostoevsky says they're so well
provided that all they have to do is
eat cakes and busy themselves with the
reproduction of the species all day
so you could think about it as a
realization in a sense as a concrete
realization of an economic utopia you
don't have to work everything you want
is provided for you so everyone's happy
and dostoyevsky says well you have to be
out of your mind to think that everyone
would be happy under those circumstances
because people are fundamentally insane
and so that if you gave people
perfection
the first thing they would do once they
got bored three quarters to death which
would take about a week is run around
looking for something to smash just to
cause some trouble just so that there'd
be an interesting problem and i think
well you can see that the relationship
between that and the uh and
the events in in uh in the book of
genesis at the beginning you know
because god tells eve don't mock about
you know be satisfied with what you've
got and her curiosity impels her to go
interact with the one thing in the whole
place that she shouldn't interact with
and then all hell breaks loose and then
you have to ask yourself is that a good
thing or a bad thing and what dostoevsky
concludes is that
that's a good thing is it's that that
fundamental
experience seeking disruptive element of
the human psyche is actually the best
thing about it and the idea that we
could quell its operation but by
providing what's essentially uh you know
a
return to the womb is something you know
you could think about it that way where
you have no problems to think that that
would actually solve the problem is not
only
absurdly immature but also just false on
the face of it you think well
first of all that's an amazing
conclusion i mean think about that
dostoevsky's thought that through he
figured out what was wrong with the idea
of communist utopia 40 years before the
russian revolution i mean it's
unbelievable not only did he see what
was coming he saw what was wrong with it
you know and you could say the same
thing about nietzsche although i don't
think nietzsche ever read wrote anything
that has the
like
concentrated narrative punch of notes
from underground and what happens in the
in in notes from underground in some
sense is it's a novel about
someone attempting to take nietzsche's
route to being a superman a lot of
dostoevsky's novels are about that so
raskolnikov for example in crime and
punishment who ends up being a murderer
essentially tries to transform himself
into a nietzschean superman beyond good
and evil making his own values and
dostoyevsky plays that out and his
conclusion is
don't break rules that you don't
understand because if you do something
will take you down and that's basically
what happens to raskolnikov he kills
his
the pawn broker and the pawn brokers
slave
slash niece kills them with an axe he
gets away with it
he gets away with it no one has any idea
that he does it and he has access to all
her money which he promptly buries in i
think in an abandoned lot and wants
absolutely nothing to do with but you
know was constantly haunted by what he's
done and keeps revisiting that area you
know and then a prosecutor starts to
suspect him even there's no reason to
and basically
subjects him to a chinese water torture
he just
taps him and taps him and taps him and
taps him and taps him until he starts to
break down and eventually confesses and
the cat and mouse game played by the
prosecutor and raskolnikov is absolutely
psychologically terrified i've never
seen anything like that in any piece of
literature because dostoevsky was smart
enough to figure out exactly how you
would torment someone with a guilty
conscience into confessing and the
prosecutor is patient
he just plays him like you play a fish
well and ruskolnikov undergoes a
we won't worry about the end of the
story because it's not that relevant
in notes from underground a similar
thing happens is that
this narrator who's so pathological and
railing against his own cowardice and
his own resentment and his own weakness
and
but also
not
having any not granting any credence to
the idea of of a
future modern utopia he he tries to
reconstruct his own character and the
way he does that is he ends up
in a relationship with this woman who's
been forced into prostitution which was
a very common
consequence of female poverty in that
era because well because everyone was
absolutely dirt poor to begin with and
because
the alternatives were few and far
between if you fell out of your social
class for for any reason
and he decides that he's going to redeem
her he's going to improve her life he's
going to rescue her and so the last part
of the book is about him trying to
rescue her but he fails because he just
doesn't you know he takes on this job
which is to help someone in real trouble
and like
helping someone in real trouble i would
say is you bloody well better be careful
before you try that because real trouble
is real trouble and the probability that
you'll have the wherewithal to help
instead of making it worse is very very
low and that's exactly what happens to
him he sort of he he attempts mostly
both both
he sort of becomes narcissistic in his
estimation of his redemptive capability
but there's part of where part of him is
motivated by a general a genuine desire
to help but when push comes to shove he
can't tolerate
the responsibility that it would take to
follow it through and he ends up
betraying her and so of course she ends
up in worse condition than she was to
begin with so
it's an absolutely amazing novel and
there's more to it and i should tell you
about this too so the palace of crystal
was actually a reference to an actual
building
and the building was a building
that was erected
in england in london for the world's
fair that was held at that point and it
was the first steel and glass building
of any size and so it was a forerunner
of
you know our our
our modern downtowns and the reason in
part that every downtown in the world
looks the same if it was built say
between the 1950s and the 1970s 1980s
the 70s were in particular absolutely
appalling but
you know that was the new international
style and and it was was originated in
germany and it was predicated on the
idea that the worker
would want a bare bone structure glass
tower completely devoid of an
ornamentation because that was all
bourgeois nonsense and that that style
should be imposed everywhere in the
world as a movement towards this sort of
workers utopia well you can see what
that did
you know so these you know i'm telling
you that because these ideas they
stretch out and they have their
tentacles everywhere you know so that
new international style that was
certainly responsible for things like
the housing projects in the united
states which were absolute
catastrophes
you know all came out of this dream of
the workers socialist paradise
well so dostoevsky goes on the rampage
against that idea on a psychological
basis he just says well don't be
you really think that human beings are
constructed so that if you give them
enough to eat they'll be satisfied it's
like that's not what we're like at all
we're not even close to like that we're
full of snakes and twists and insanity
and you know and he makes that case
very straightforwardly and says
not only are we like that but that it's
a really it's the best thing about us
that we're like that it's a remarkable
remarkable book
so
okay so well then we might say well what
happened
when these utopian schemes were put into
action
all right so
solzhenitsyn described what happened in
the soviet union in the nigu-like
archipelago
and he estimated that the st the soviets
killed 60 million people between 1919
and 1959 roughly speaking now people
have taken them to task for that
estimate but there's no good records and
certainly
the
it's between 25 and 60 million and you
know you might say well
really
doesn't matter is that actually the
point once you're past your first 10
million you've already established your
your character i would say you know and
stalin said one death is a tragedy and a
million deaths is a statistic
which pretty much gives you some insight
into how stellar thought
so
what happened in in in the ussr
well
here's the stat for you so
czar you know
before the ussr
russia was tsarist right and so it was a
monarchy like most european countries
were monarchies except
it was more
feudal than most european countries
certainly far more than england say or
france
and
the radicals regarded the czar
as an oppressor
and so it was the oppression of the
tsarists the tsar and the aristocracy
that was partly
what provided the impetus for the
workers slash peasants because they were
mostly peasants in russia to rise up you
know against
let's say
for the sake of simplicity their class
enemies
from 1825
to 19
i think it was 1900.
it's right around 1900 75 years
the czarists sentenced 6 000 people to
death for political crimes and executed
3 000.
in the years from 1919 to 1959 the
communists killed 30 million
so when we're thinking about
the communist revolution as a revolution
against tyranny and a justifiable
revolution against tyranny we should be
very careful what it is that we're
defining as tyranny now if you want to
know what the russian
camps were like for prisoners
you can read dostoevsky's house of the
dead because what happened to
dostoyevsky is he was one of those
people who was more or less sentenced by
the tsar he was a student radical they
threw him in prison took him out one day
pretended to shoot him
in a firing squad used blanks
shorted him out completely there there's
some evidence that that's when his
epilepsy either started or really became
intense and then they banished him to a
prison in siberia and the prison was
full of thieves and murderers and
rapists and it was a rough place and you
know dostoevsky was an aristocratic guy
an educated person a young man he had no
idea what to expect and so he wrote a
book called the house of the dead which
is a very interesting book but if you
read the house of the dead
and then you read the goo like
archipelago you think that
like the the house of the dead was a
it was a caribbean
caribbean holiday camp compared to the
gulag i mean
when the prisoners
in the prison camps in
in dostoevsky's prison sorry used to go
into the villages which they did they
could go into the villages i mean they
were guarded and all that but they could
go there to work the people would come
out and give them food little kids would
come up to them and give them food
because one of the characteristics of
russian culture at that point was that
the peasants in particular felt that the
people who were imprisoned were
unfortunates you know they felt bad for
them it was part of their orthodox
christian charity and they also felt
that maybe they were only one step from
the same thing and so their basic
attitude was charitable and you know
they were fed in the prisons like i mean
it was hardly
gourmet fair but of course everybody was
so damn poor at that time that that's
not even a reasonable comparison and you
know it was rough but it wasn't
it wasn't the most imaginative rough you
could possibly imagine for the most
pointless possible purpose ending up in
your death and likely your family's
death it wasn't that and you know you
got out of those camps you got out you
do your sons and then they would let you
go they might exile you but even if you
were exiled you could have a life there
so that was the extent of the judicial
and penitential
tyranny of the czars
you know and you know i'm not saying
that the czarist system was
all sweetness and light but
i don't think that's relevant it was
part of the feudal system it had
developed organically in some sense
across history the russians were sort of
on the
slow end of the developmental curve but
but it was a hell of a lot better than
what came afterwards
so
after the the soviets after lenin took
over now lenin stepped in when when when
lenin stepped in to take power russia
was basically in chaos
what had happened was world war one
which was you know a frenzy of insanity
and basically marked the end of the
monarchical system in europe it also
marked by the way the dissolution of the
ottoman empire and the fragmentation of
the middle east and so part of the
reason that the middle east is parsed up
the way it is today is because the
ottoman empire collapsed england and
france still had some dominion there as
victors in world war one and they
created the middle eastern countries out
of the wreckage of the ottoman empire so
you know we're still playing out the
consequences of that but it's something
useful to know that's how that came
about the empire collapsed but all the
monarchical
empires essentially collapsed after
world war one
russia was devastated the soldiers were
were deserting the trenches on maas and
coming home partly because the tsar had
abdicated after he took control of the
armed forces things went south even
further he abdicated and the new
parliament which was sort of half
democratic and half socialist i would
say was starting to divide up the land
among the peasants and so the soldiers
were very motivated to get the hell home
so that they could get some of this land
but the whole country that the
overarching political system had
collapsed
and the russians were starting to
organize themselves from the bottom up
at that point and there was the hints of
a new governmental structure in in
moscow and this was this democratic
socialist alliance but there was still a
terrible power vacuum and the central
authorities in moscow never really
seemed to get control of the country and
it was into that mess that lenin stepped
and so
you know sometimes when there's an
extraordinarily chaotic situation it
just takes one seed of order so to speak
to spread itself out everywhere it's
like the yin and yang symbol and that's
what happened
but
so the marxist idea was that
the thing that made people's lives
intolerable was basically differences in
distribution that had been
stabilized into class differences and so
the classes were basically the
proletariat and the bourgeoisie and the
bourgeoisie were the owners
and so if you owned anything the theory
was that
since everything of value was created by
workers the only way you could have any
excess value was essentially if you s
stole it if you took it so you were by
definition an oppressor by definition
and that part of the move towards the
socialist utopia was that
the bourgeoisie would dissolve as a
class well the
communists were a little
impatient for the spontaneous
dissolution of the bourgeoisie so what
they decided to do was just
proactively dissolve it and so
what the nazis did to the jews and and
the other people that they persecuted
for
the manner in which they were born
roughly speaking the communists did to
people who
to people by class and so essentially if
you were educated
and you owned any property
or if someone just didn't like you and
you were a little richer than anywhere
anyone else you were going to be dead
and so they sent
wave after wave of radical brutalized
resentful
mobs into the russian countryside and
raped and pillaged and killed everyone
who was competent
and so part of that was direct
so that you know a mob would storm your
house now you have to understand that
often when these outside agitators came
into the village there was enough
outside agitators so that they could do
the storming by themselves but they
would pick up
adherence in the village and those would
be the adherents who wanted to go out to
someone's house and you know strip it of
all its valuables and
have their way with the people inside
and so you can imagine what sort of
people that attracted
obviously the highest quality of person
and so they go out to a kulak house and
surround it now often the peasants would
fight
them off with pitchforks trying to
defend the people inside the house and
you know that worked sometime but most
of the time it didn't work and then
they'd go in and they take everything
absolutely everything out of the house
and
leave it with nothing and then
and leave the people with nothing and
then eventually those people the ones
that survived which weren't that many
the government offered them the
opportunity to be taken out to siberia
to start a new life they could bring two
months worth of food in their families
and go out there but of course they
didn't have two months worth of food
because everything had been stolen from
them and then when they got to siberia
there was nothing left nothing there
except crowded camps that immediately
produced typhus and killed all the
children
so that was that was the beginning of
the russian revolution and it was lenin
who did that so if you if you read
communist revisionists they'll basically
say well things were going all
hunky-dory under lenin because he had
everyone's best interests in mind and
then that monster stalin got control of
the party and that's when it became a
cult of personality that had nothing to
do with true communism you know that's
the rationale but
lenin was just as good a monster as
stalin he just didn't live very long he
died in about 1922 1923 something around
that and he'd already produced stalin as
his follow-up monster at that point
you know and that was just things just
barely got going at that point you know
the next thing was after they got rid of
all the cool acts they collectivized the
farms which meant if you had a farm you
were some damn peasant you just got some
land you know because your your parents
were basically they weren't they were
basically slaves for all intents and
purposes they were attached to the land
and so you just got some land that some
of you were smart enough so that you
made something out of it you were
growing food at the same time to feed
everyone
so and you know in any
in any creative enterprise any creative
enterprise whatsoever it's a minority of
the people who do all the productive
work
so you know if you have 100 farmers 10
of them grow half the food if you have a
thousand farmers 30 of them grow half
the food
so you go out there and you wipe out
your most productive people it's like
well guess what happens next
well you you wipe them out and then you
forcibly collectivize and so everyone
who had nothing and who was completely
useless is thrilled about that but the
next thing that happens is well hey you
don't grow any crops
and so
that's what happened food production
plummeted and then
for a variety of reasons the central
soviets weren't very happy with the
ukrainians and so what they decided was
that they were going to take all the
food that the ukrainian collectivist
farmers managed to grow anyways which
wasn't very much and ship it to the
cities and so they did that and then
they prosecuted women who would go out
into the fields with their children to
pick up individual grains of wheat that
the gleaners that the threshers had
missed and the punishment for that was
that you were incarcerated in a death
camp
and so six million ukrainians starved
and cannibalism was so rife in the
ukraine in the 1930s that the soviet
government printed posters saying it is
barbaric to eat your children so you
might say well that's a little too
little a little too late so that was the
first six million deaths not counting
all you know
the russian civil war and all the deaths
that went along there and that just
basically got the ball rolling you know
while that was happening the the goo
like camps that stellar that
solzhenitsyn wrote about were well onto
being established and that's where it
was enslaved labor camps roughly
speaking that the soviets produced
enough of their economic goods to keep
lumbering along with these forced
five-year plan projects that made
everyone into a liar and so that's the
next part of the story so
solzhenitsyn probably has done a better
job of documenting this than anyone else
i ever read
but it's uh it's also something that
orwell talked a lot about and you know i
think that the best introduction to this
idea is probably 1984 because it's a
short book you know
and basically what happens in 1984 is
it's a it's a satire of communist
totalitarianism
clearly
and i mean expressly that's exactly what
it is and basically
the rule was in the society of 1984 that
you were not allowed to think or say
anything that wasn't part of the
prevailing dogma of the times and one of
the things that happens in 1984 is that
there's three big blocks power blocks
and they're always at war with one
another except who they're at war with
schiff so at one point it's i think one
of them is called oceana i don't
remember exactly but these two power
blocks are at war and then all of a
sudden that switches these two power
blocks at war and so then all the
history textbooks are revised and all
the news stories are revised so it's as
if we were always at war with that
particular block and you know that can
change on a whim
and so everyone is required to parrot
the beliefs of the state and to praise
it continually no criticism whatsoever
and
everyone in the entire state is an
informer or at least enough people so
that the probability that you're going
to get nailed if you ever say anything
that you actually think is near 100
and the informers are continually
rewarded which is exactly what happened
in the soviet union so if you were some
nasty bit of work
with your three families in your 150
square foot apartment which would have
been about what you could expect and you
were hoping that maybe your son and
daughter could have their own place and
you saw someone down the hallway that
you didn't like or had an animus against
or
or whatever
a couple of words to the proper
authorities and they come charging in at
two in the morning with their jack boots
and you know take everyone out bring
them to the central prison shave them
bald strip them of their clothes put
them in ill-fitting uniform and they
were gone
and then you got their apartment
so that was the basis of the soviet
state
so
you know you should just imagine for a
while what that would be like and so one
of the soldier nissan's points and this
was something that was echoed by viktor
frankl but solzhenitsyn does the best
job of documenting this was that
first of all he takes the marxist
presuppositions as a set of axioms
and he says
well one possibility is that these
axioms were never put into practice
properly so let's look at that idea and
then he says well you know there's a
couple of problems with that because
here's how the axioms were put into
practice in the soviet union
directly as a consequence of the axioms
themselves which is like private
property is theft you know the
bourgeoisie is a is a parasitical class
that um
you know that that that everything
should be collectivized and equal among
everyone those are the basic
presuppositions and that was exactly
what was put into practice and used his
justification for everything they did so
that's a non-starter and then he also
points out well we don't just have the
soviet union as an example we have the
soviet union we have china which was
even worse we have vietnam we have
cambodia where paul pott who was trained
in france at the sorbonne by french
left-wing intellectuals went back threw
everyone out of the city and killed one
in four people in cambodia in the space
of about 10 years and then of course we
still have north korea and we also have
the fact that the only countries in
africa that suffered
like deadly famines in the 20th century
were those that were run by communist
dictators
so how much bloody evidence do you need
you know and so people say and i've had
people say this to me is you know that
wasn't true communism and i think what
that means is that person has the
following delusion
if they were the leader of the communist
party at that time things would have
turned out better and the probability of
that is
first of all if you were the sort of
person who was good
the chance that you would live through
the massacres and get to the top was
zero there wasn't a chance of that you
know so the system basically produced
its own breed of horrible monster to
lead it and there was no standing in its
way you know if you had an iota of
compassion
and dared to express that i mean think
about what you're doing if you stand up
in a system like that and act
compassionately you're an immediate
judge of every single person around you
who doesn't want to do that well you're
not going to live through that that's
for sure you know they'll call you an
enemy of the state or whatever the hell
it is you're going to be gone in no time
flat
so
what soldier hits and so okay so orwell
made the proposition that
states like that could only exist if
everyone in them was trained to lie and
the training was
the idea of training isn't exactly
orwell's notion
willing to
and punished if they didn't both of
those at the same time
and so that's where the idea of
orwellian double speak comes from you
know and that's when you say one thing
but mean another you say something that
is in accordance with the you know the
tenets of the time but it's a euphemism
to cover up something terrible that's
going on
and so
1984 is the story of a person who
basically gets tangled up in that and
they find his worst fear
uh he's afraid of rats and they punish
him with his worst fear and the way they
punish him is by putting a
uh like a muzzle like a goalie mask or
like a umpire's mask on his face except
it's this long and they put a starving
rat inside that and tie it to his head
and so
that's
1984.
but that's exactly the sort of thing
that happened in the gulag prisons you
know i mean
perhaps not the rat thing precisely but
it doesn't really matter and the other
thing the soviets did was that if they
threw you in one of their prison camps
you had to sign a confession admitting
that you were wrong
which was its own particular kind of
evil you know the nazis if they gathered
you up and
the lines were clear-cut
it was irrelevant your innocence or
guilt as a person was irrelevant you
know you were the member of a racial
group deemed unacceptable and so you
were dead but the soviets they actually
managed to figure out how to make that
even worse so that not only were you
destroyed as a consequence of your birth
but class not race but you had to also
admit that you were an enemy of the
state and sign that before they would
kill you and so most people did and
unsurprising you know there were people
who didn't but
but they were few and far between and
you know of course that's not surprising
i mean how much
punishment do you think someone can take
in solzhenitsyn's book there are stories
of people who didn't give in you know
and those people are so damn tough you
just can't even
he said that was actually what
transformed solzhenitsyn in the caps
because he was a you know a moderately
committed although somewhat cynical
communist on entry into the camps but
then he saw people in there who were
absolutely unwilling to falsify any of
their experience and lie no matter what
happened to them under any conditions
whatsoever and he was so amazed by that
that
it actually produced a transformation in
this character and part of what the
gulag archipelago is about is exactly
that transformation
and his discovery of the what you might
describe as the individual
responsibility to truth in the face of
state tyranny
you know and solzhenitsyn's basic
conclusion was and this is a conclusion
by the way that dostoyevsky had drawn 70
years previously was that
an individual who stops lying could
bring down a totalitarian state
and so it's a very interesting claim
you know because solange nissan's
conclusion from his detailed analysis
and all his personal experience inside
the camps was that no matter how
powerful the totalitarian state was that
in the final analysis it couldn't stand
up to actual truth
now it's a very radical claim
but it's borne out in part by his
experience because of course
solzhenitsyn did tell the truth
and his
book the gulag archipelago was one of
the things that
it well it was the book that demolished
the credibility of communism as a
political structure
so he managed it you know
the first book that he wrote called a
lot a day in the life of viaban
denisovich was published in 1962.
so what happened was stalin
died or was killed in the late 1950s i
think it was in 1957 but
it was somewhere between 1957 and 1959
and khrushchev took over now there's
some evidence that khrushchev and two
other people killed stalin because they
thought he was going to invade europe
with his hydrogen bombs
and stalin had already demonstrated
quite clearly that if he had to you know
drop a hydrogen bomb on paris and london
to make sure that the europeans got the
hell out of the way that that wasn't
something that was certainly that he was
certainly willing to do
so khrushchev was one of the people who
was involved in stella's death and he
took over but khrushchev was also one of
the main architects of the ukrainian
famine
but khrushchev had actually developed a
bit of a conscience about all that and
he loosened things up substantially for
a period of time for about five years
and during that time solzhenitsyn
released a book called one day in the
life of ivan denisovich
which is a story about himself
and it's just one day in a goo like
archipelago cap
and so it's a very dreary and and
wretched and horrifying book but it was
the first of anything like that that was
seen in the soviet union and another bit
of evidence that was disseminated out
into the west in 1962 which the bloody
french intellectuals could have picked
up right there and then and said oh look
you know our our glorious leader has a
lot more problems than we think but of
course that never happened
but then
and
khrushchev was actually loosening up the
strictures in the in the ussr but he got
wiped out of power in a coup and taken
out of power and the clamps came back
down and you know khrushchev was sent
off to live in his in exile in his dasha
i don't remember which one that's his
you know vacation home until he died in
about 1980.
so
but you know there were a few cracks
that appeared at exactly that time and
of course that was also at the height of
the cold war because it was 1962 when
kennedy and khrushchev faced off over
cuba and you know that was one of the
places where we got this far away from
you know total annihilation
now solzhenitsyn's proposition was that
had
people refused to lie
the soviet government could have never
taken hold or maintained itself
so he believed that you know because
there's a lot of theories about how a
society becomes corrupt right
so like let's say you take the example
of nazi germany
you might say it's the following orders
idea
right
the power structure is taken over by
thugs and then
what you're doing when you carry out the
orders of the thugs is
merely responding out of fear you're a
good person but you know you'd be put in
a terrible situation and there's
terrible pressure being brought to bear
on you and that's why you go do the
things that you do
and so that theory is predicated on the
idea that there's no real relationship
between the populace and the government
and that the government is basically
taken over by a coup and the people who
organize the coup are well distributed
enough and aggressive enough to maintain
authority by punishment under all
circumstances whatsoever
the problem with that theory is that it
doesn't seem to be true
so
the first issue is
did hitler create the germans or did the
germans create hitler or could you say
that they were involved in a dance well
jung's take on that because jung spent a
lot of time studying what the hell was
going on in germany and by his own
admission got caught up in it for a
short period of time he said when he was
there that the
the illness so to speak was so
overwhelming that it was virtually
impossible not to get caught up in it
and i you know i think people
underestimate the degree to which what
they think is true and false is a
consequence of the milieu that they've
been placed in
but i think and this is partly from
reading jung that hitler and the germans
co-created each other and the union
explanation for that was something like
i'm going to update it a bit modernize
it
in a crowd you have dispersal of
responsibility everyone knows about that
and that means you can do whatever you
want in a crowd you can say whatever you
want you can act however you want
because you're not going to be held
individually responsible for it so jung
would say the crowd has the capacity of
allowing the shadow to emerge and then
he believed that what happened was the
crowd shadow had a dialogue often
non-verbal with hitler with hitler's
imagination and so hitler who was a
great rhetorician
i don't know if that's a word
um
would talk in his emotional oratory to
the crowd and the crowd would respond in
one way or another and so hitler would
be guided by their response and being an
imaginative person
cobbling together what the crowd is
encouraging in him to speak that
produces a kind of a theory and you know
hitler is able to flesh out that theory
populist leaders do that you know it's
so i talked to
preston manning at one point preston
manning started the reform party in
alberta
and it eventually
merged with the conservatives so it was
kind of an offshoot of the conservative
party and there's always been left and
right-wing offshoot parties that are
generated in canada almost always in the
west and
i invited him to talk to a group of
people that i had brought together to
tell us how he managed to create a whole
political party in like 10 years now he
was the son of a premier who was a
right-wing premier
so he had his connections and that was
part of it but he said you know he'd go
to there was a lot of
western separatist
agitation at that point and and people
in alberta
some of the political leaders thought
that that would become powerful enough
so that it would actually you know be a
movement to contend with and partly what
they were doing with the formation of
the reform party was to take some of the
pressure off that side of things
so anyways they started to go around to
talk to people in arenas mostly and
manning would give a speech but he said
the thing that he liked best was the
question and answer at the end and that
what the reform party did was derive its
policies from the question and answer
sessions so you could imagine that you
know the crowd had concerns which were
allowed to be expressed in an
articulated fashion and the party built
a lot of its doctrines as a consequence
of that conversation and of course that
was partly what accounted for its rapid
popularity because it was actually
addressing the desires of the crowd
and so you know you could even say well
that's how a democracy should function
you know but
but that also assumes that the
democratic
systems and conventions
are in place to protect against you know
let's say just a mass movement that goes
off radically to the left erratically to
the right it was still all taking place
within a perfectly functional
monarchical democracy
but
by his own
admission and will
the policies were shaped by the crowd
okay well the same thing happened with
hitler except it happened in an
underground and pathological way and the
people he was addressing were in a hell
of a lot worse shape than albertans in
1980 you know because they just got back
from the trenches
all you know a huge chunk of the young
men were dead the rest that weren't were
brutalized beyond belief the economy was
in shambles the french had imposed an
incredibly punitive um
you know peace treaty
uh germany had lost most of its
industrial
uh centers as part of the redistribution
of land after world war one and then the
whole bloody economy collapsed because
the german government inflated the
currency to wipe out their debt to the
to the allies and just reduced its value
to zero so people were not happy they
were seriously not happy and so that was
the crowd that hitler was addressing
so
now one of the issues might be well
where does the
this is where things get so tricky when
you're trying to figure out exactly how
these things are caused
my sense
i would i took a political science
degree before i became a psychologist
because i was interested in this sort of
thing but i became
aware quite early that
almost all the explanations that the
political scientists were offering were
economic and you know to me that means
they were all derived from theories on
the left roughly speaking because it's
the left that constantly claims that the
primary motivations for people are
economic you know i mean the right
does this i won't talk about that for
the moment because it's it's just not
relevant in the context of the
university and i thought that's just not
right there's all sorts of motivations
that people have that aren't economic
it's not there's lots of things it
doesn't take into account it doesn't
take into account
well it doesn't take into account the
fact that people have a psyche and that
that psyche is perfectly capable of
desiring good things as well as terrible
things it's like well what how are you
going to account for that
i mean economics makes someone into a
suicide bomber i don't think so like
economics plays a role obviously but
there's lots of people who are under
severe economic pressure who do not
become you know mass shooters in the
united states or suicide farmers you
need a hell of a lot more explanation
than that
and so i was very very interested in the
uh
in the moral questions that underlie
especially things like what happened in
nazi germany in the concentration camps
because it seemed to me that the moral
question was paramount
how could people do the sorts of things
that they did in the concentration camps
you know there's a psychological issue
there
so
that's when i started to read jung and
solzhenitsyn in particular and orwell
and a lot of the people that i've been
talking to you about
in this book i started last night the
black book of communism
in the introduction they talked about
different approaches to history
you know and
there there is a
positivist approach to history
where there's never any moral judgment
rendered
you know
and
that was the position putatively taken
to many people who conducted an analysis
of the 20th century but my sense is is
that there's some things that have
happened that are so brutal and terrible
that to
treat that from a positivist perspective
is in itself a form of complicity it's
like because at some point you have to
make a decision
was what happened in auschwitz wrong or
not it's a simple question
you can say
it wasn't it wasn't wrong because the
standards of right and wrong are
generated locally
and there's no ultimate
standard against which they can be
judged
and so their their their constructions
their local constructions of convenience
and even if you're not happy with the
results they produce that doesn't mean
you get to say they were wrong
or you can say to hell with that
i don't care what your rationalization
is if you perform this kind of action
then what you're doing is wrong and then
i should also say that
that was actually formally determined
after world war ii right because after
world war ii the nazi leaders were
subjected to the nuremberg trials
and that's where the idea of crimes
against humanity emerged war crimes and
crimes against humanity and the basic
principle there's a few of them but the
basic principle between the uh behind
the idea that there can be crimes
against humanity is that it's wrong to
kill someone
for the manner in which they were
born so that's the basic principle so
that could be race obviously
um could be language it could be gender
could be class whatever it's wrong well
okay
a cynic would say
has to say yeah yeah
had the germans won the war the laws
would have been different so that was
just a law written by the victors and
the cynic would also say well then i
don't know exactly what you say i guess
the next thing you say is you can't
appeal to universal principles that
transcend culture
because people are cultural creatures
only
which is by the way also the claim of
the radical left because one of the
things that the radical left wanted to
do in places like the soviet union in
china and cambodia and so forth was to
produce the new man
and the idea was
wipe out the past really wipe it out and
mao went a long way to doing that
because part of the cultural revolution
involved the wholesale destruction of
almost all of china's history prior to
1960. so that's another thing that we
can thank the radical communists for is
they destroyed chinese culture all that
history
done and part of the reason for that was
that they ideologically presumed that
that culture was transforming people
into the wrong sort of person and so
we're going to wipe the slate clean
which mao was perfectly willing to do
and generate the new human being out of
the ashes and underneath that is the
presupposition that there's no such
thing as human nature it's all cultural
and the logical conclusion from that or
our logical conclusion is a people are
completely malleable so that's the
radical social constructionist position
which i would say is also the position
of most academics at universities now
you know that things like gender are
socially constructed it's like okay it's
fine like take your goddamn argument to
its logical conclusion oh no i can't do
that why not because you don't know
anything about i don't know anything
about history i'm completely ignorant of
anything outside of my little narrow
domain of specialization and who cares
about the 100 million dead people
so you know you can't adopt a
philosophical or an ideological position
without being willing to see what it's
done and to think that to think through
the consequences and so you say well
people are completely malleable from a
cultural perspective what that means is
that i can decide if i have the power to
make you into anything i want because
it's just arbitrary after all
or you can take a different position and
the position is fundamentally i would
say this is the fundamental position of
western democracy
is that human beings have an alien
inalienable rights
and an inalienable character and as far
as i can tell that's predicated on the
roughly speaking on the idea of horus
it's that idea is that the person is the
center of the kind of consciousness that
creates the world as it acts
you know because one of the things i was
curious about
when i was working on these ideas i
thought okay look the communists have
one worldview and the western
democracies have another
and you could say
it's just a battle between ideologies
and you would also say under those
circumstances that all belief systems
are nothing but ideologies and that's
the radical social constructivist
viewpoint right it's like uh
it's its behavior isn't in some sense
taken to its extreme right human beings
are a blank slate well first of all
they're not we know that there's enough
biology being we've studied enough
biology over the last hundred years that
we can just dispense with that idea it's
wrong but anyways
we'll give the devil it's due okay it's
an ideological conflict between
communism and
and the west okay it's arbitrary doesn't
matter who wins but the war is the wars
between these two belief systems well
why is that a flawed argument
well people weren't flocking into soviet
union as immigrants they were trying
desperately to escape which is why there
was a wall in germany and if you went
over the wall they shot you okay that
doesn't look so good well then there's
all the deaths 35 million of them that
seems to indicate that you know there's
a bit more
happening on the pathological end in one
society than on the other and then the
next thing i was curious about is okay
where the hell did the idea of
inalienable rights come from
like is that just something arbitrary is
it just an invention or is it based on
something that's real and you know what
is real mean and so that's when i
started to trace the emergence of the
idea back as far as i could trace it and
so first of all that was political so
maybe that manifested itself in the most
articulated form during the
enlightenment but that isn't where it
started because in the 13th century the
english had come up with the magna carta
already and so there was idea that you
know the people had some sovereignty
that the monarchy was not allowed to
steal and that was the origin of the
idea of parliamentary democracy but that
emerged out of another idea and that was
the judeo-christian idea that everyone
had value before god i thought okay well
what the hell does that mean you know
because you might say well if that's the
case and we've dispensed with the idea
of god then the whole idea of natural
rights false which by the way was
nietzsche's prediction he thought as
soon as we wiped out the classical
underlying structure that the whole idea
of rights would just disintegrate well
that's exactly what happened in the
soviet union and china and so forth you
know and it
we'll see it might not happen
here but it wouldn't surprise me if it
did
okay so then i thought well is there
anything that might lead lend some
validity in any way to that claim first
of all what does the claim mean that
people have value before god also i went
back to the to the you know the
theological stories and the religious
history and tried to figure out exactly
where this idea had come from and what
it meant and i found that you could just
trace it farther and farther and farther
and farther back so you know it
disappears that mesopotamia
but then
it doesn't disappear because if you look
at wolf packs and chimp troops and
social animals in general
they organize their societies as if each
of the individuals in the hierarchy have
value because the wolves for example
like if there's a dominance dispute
between two wolves one wins one turns
its neck over and says you know tear out
my throat and the other wolf says now
you're annoying but we'll keep you
around because you're useful well it's
this it's the same idea the idea is that
the individual has integral worth in
relationship to the group and then
that's not an ideological idea that's an
idea that's based as far as i can tell
in evolution and it's really really deep
it goes back as far as you can chase it
so that means it's not just an
ideological conflict well okay
maybe that's wrong but i can't see
anywhere that it's wrong well don't all
ideologies like arguably come from like
evolutionary
uh
okay so so that's a good question okay
so the question is
you know i parceled off one set of
beliefs as specifically grounded in
evolutionary
in evolution okay i'm going to make two
distinctions
first there's a difference between an
idea that's grounded in evolution and an
idea that's grounded in evolutionary
theory
okay so the marxists were were grounded
in evolutionary theory they have
psychobiological justifications for
their claims
i know i know it isn't i just want to
dispense with that first okay so then i
was thinking
well
what exactly do ideologies do because
obviously they're also not constructed
just arbitrarily because they wouldn't
be attractive to people if they were
they have to be
and i thought well like if you look for
example at
mao or sorry marx
stalin and lennon so you could think of
them as the trinity of the ussr well i
think part of the reason that the
trinitarian idea worked as a as a you
know as a means of propaganda was
because russia was an orthodox christian
country and it had the trinitarian idea
already you know
laid down in its unconscious
well you remember i showed you that
diagram of
chaos on the outside and then the great
mother and then the great father and
then the individual and the valence of
each of them i think what happens with
an ideology and i did point this out
that out at the time but it's worth
revisiting is that the ideology
capitalizes on certain aspects of that
story it doesn't tell the whole truth
so it says for example
the individual is all good
the state is corrupt and mother nature
is good okay that's rousseau
and that's the environmentalist movement
okay because it's grounded in russoian
thinking via thorough for example and
then you have the opposite which is
hobbes and hobb says the individual is
you know
a catastrophe of conflicts and
aggression
the state has to be the state is the
only thing that can possibly keep the
individual in check and that predicts it
protects us from the ultimate chaos of
nature well those are both true
and you can derive ideologies from them
but i think their weaknesses is they
don't take the other side into account
and i don't think that you can say that
about the traditions that i've been
describing i think they've been around
two so you look at egypt for example the
story has all the elements
it has
the adversary so that's seth right it
has the good king and that's osiris and
it has isis as queen of the underworld
she's going to pause like she's she's
not as well differentiated in the story
but the elements are still there and you
have horus and it says says look life is
this landscape and all these characters
are participating think yeah that's them
that's as close as we can get to a
narrative truth and part of the reason i
wanted to teach this course once i
thought i'd figured these things out was
to provide people with the defense
against ideology it's like someone tells
you
a story that's causal here's how history
laid itself out okay it's plausible like
the russo story is plausible and so is
the um
hogsian story they're not only they're
plausible they're true but they're only
true like this
you know
and the other one's true like this but
you want to know where's the other half
of the story
people are inherently good and society
corrupts them yes
people are inherently evil and society
regulates them yes
and it's hard on people because you know
the classic
idea of western logic is that one thing
can't be itself and it's opposite at the
same time
but that only applies to unitary things
and like a human being is not a unitary
thing and neither is a state
so
so well so that's the best answer that i
have to that question social like an
ideology um is like an incomplete
narrative
it's exactly what it is that's why it
has its power because it can extract its
mode of power from the underlying
archetypes which which relates them to
the motivations that you just described
like
there is a pronounced demand for
egalitarianism in human beings
it's agreeableness the trading
agreeableness so the more agreeable you
are the more egalitarian you are why
because people should share and get
along it's especially true within the
confines of a family or tribal unit
right where everyone's pulling together
and cooperating it isn't obvious to me
that it's a useful ethic once you get
beyond
like a kin group size
i think you need conscientiousness then
because conscientiousness is more like a
cold virtue
and it's the thing that supports um
success in bureaucracies if you're
conscientious you go into a large
landscape of unrelated people so maybe a
functional bureaucracy and
conscientiousness predicts your success
but conscientiousness and agreeableness
are orthogonal to one another they do
not have the same value structure
and the truth of the matter is is that
they both wouldn't exist if they weren't
both necessary
egalitarianism is necessary because
otherwise the hierarchies get so damn
steep that the people at the bottom die
and the whole system collapses
but agreeableness is as a universal
ethic is no good because it doesn't
allow for distinctions of quality
and it doesn't allow any decisions to be
made because if a hundred people have to
come to a consensus before action can
take place well
someone with a hierarchy who's invading
you
they're just going to wipe you out
you're so slow
so there's this tension and it is partly
the tension between
it's the tension between the far left
and the right because the best marker
for the far left is agreeableness in
terms of a personality dimension that
predicts question you mentioned earlier
that like
why didn't you apply the same logic we
said before you can say um the
individual right stuff that you're
working within yourself as an elementary
guys better than the culture of the
product rather than for the nature why
can't you
say that's also one-sided and they
connect to the other side
well i think the reason that i don't
think that that's appropriate is
precisely the reason that i told you the
egyptian and the mesopotamian stories i
mean the first reason i told you those
stories was to show you that those
stories exist
and they can't be taken lightly because
those stories are the products of tens
of thousands of years of thought like
they're not just any old story and so
and what the stories seem to indicate is
that there has to be a dynamic
relationship between
the vision of the individual and the
integrity of the state it isn't saying
that one of those is more important than
the other at all it's saying that in
order for one to remain healthy in order
for both to remain healthy there has to
be a constant dialectic of communication
and so
then you you could say and people have
said this how do you know this isn't
just another ideology
well
i i tried to i tried to explain why that
is it looks to me like ideologies only
take and i don't know how to define that
because i'm trying to figure it out
part of that was grounded in the
question
was it just ideology that drove the
distinction between the west and the
soviet union
for me it was hopeless if it was
because it was just ideology
there wasn't right on either side and it
was just
an endless battle
it was an endless battle it was because
one of the things i realized was
and this is
was the most dismal part of going
through all this material for me because
i thought that that it was done
like i came to the conclusion at one
point
i mean for whatever relevance it has
that the problem was unsolvable
technically
people were pathologized by their
self-consciousness completely
understandably it's like when someone
comes to me with an anxiety disorder i
never ask why i think no kidding
you know
it's the healthy non-anxious people that
are the mystery
so it is it's like why the hell aren't
you freaking out all the time it's a
really good question
you know it's like you're like the rat
that's in its burrow you've explored the
territory and you're calm that does not
mean you're calm it also does not mean
you're safe
it just means that for some weird reason
you can act like you are and you can
undo that like people have that undone
all the time they get traumatized and
then they start questioning and that
whole protective structure falls apart
and they're screwed they're they're
anxious they're in pain they develop
agoraphobia you know or they develop
obsessive-compulsive disorder and you
think
well yeah obviously it's like someone
comes to me and says well when i go into
a new building i always check out the
fire exits
what are you supposed to say about that
it's like
well what if the building caught on fire
well then you're dead because you don't
do that and you might say well what's
the chance of that
and the person says
one percent chance of an infinitely bad
outcome is an infinitely large risk and
there's no arguing with that it's like
how safe should you be
you can't you can't argue about that
so
i the reason that i think this isn't an
ideology is because i think you can make
a distinction between stories and meta
stories
and a story is generally an ideology
it's a partial representation of the
whole and a meta-story is an observation
about the set of all possible stories
and that's what i was trying to do in
this class and in the book it's like
okay what's the what's the landscape of
the set of all possible stories and
that's
you know the structure that i laid out
now maybe that's wrong but it's an
interesting structure because everything
has its place
order and chaos masculine and feminine
but even more importantly
good and evil
and that's the landscape and then we can
say well you can parcel out partial
stories from that and they have
functional utility and potent
motivational force but they're
dangerously one-sided unless you've
covered the entire territory
so if you look at things clearly from a
higher metastory
the perspective myth giving yourself
throughout history it's like
he suggests kind of like a
bipartisan approach to difference like
this is just the way that that is
it's like the horrors and like observer
stories
yeah well that's exactly that's exactly
how it looks to me
it is it's it's something that's outside
rationality it's embedded not in
rationality but in biology and it knows
essential claim that jung made with
regards to the collective unconscious
and part of his believe me part of what
jung was doing and this was partly in
response to what was happening mostly in
nazi germany but also to some degree in
the communist countries as he was asking
does do human beings have a nature are
we a certain way
because if we are then that should be
taken into account
you know when you're trying to construct
that political systems
and if we do have a nature well what is
it and how does it manifest itself and
what should we you know how should we
take stock of that well here's a
question for you guys okay you can think
about this for a minute
now
there was a paper published
week ago
and it was in the international journal
of psychology which isn't the world's
best psychology journal for whatever
that means but it was a large-scale
analysis of gender differences across
culture and it
concluded the same thing that all the
large-scale analysis of gender
differences across culture have
concluded in the last 15 years which is
that
the differences
taken trait by trade are rather small
quarter to a half standard deviation
which isn't it's not trivial but it
still means that along any single trait
dimension men and women are more the
same then they are different
and that those differences maximize as
societies become more egalitarian
now you have to that should have been
front page news when that was first
discovered because it completely if it's
true
it completely undermines everything that
students have been taught by radical
left-wingers since the 1960s it
completely invalidates the claim that
people are
constructed by society
because if they're constructed by
society and you make the state
egalitarian then the gender differences
disappear
but that isn't what happens not only do
they not disappear which would be bad
enough they maximize okay that's it
theory done
now you could say well the research
isn't that good it's like well that
turns out to be wrong most of it's done
with the big five personality model
which i hated until like brute necessity
made me accept because there it kept
coming and why wasn't an interesting
theory to me it's like it was annoying
bloody statisticians figure out the
structure of personality how boring you
know but when you when you analyze the
psychometrics you're done it's like
personality as encapsulated in language
has five dimensions now it's a little
rough around the edges yeah yeah
whatever it's it's there
okay
fine so how big are those differences
well if you add them up which you could
the overlap between men and women is 10
that's it so that means if you
constructed a regression equation using
the big five personality differences to
predict who is men and women man and
woman just on the basis of the responses
to the personality traits you could
identify the genders with 90 accuracy
and it's worse than that because the new
study
showed that not only do there are other
differences that exist in personality
that are that small individually but
that large in combination but there are
different differences in blood pressure
maximized in egalitarian societies
differences in the machia in the dark
triad traits the machiavellianism and i
don't remember what the other two are
maximizing egalitarian states like all
sorts of differences maximize and then
you might ask well why is that and
there's a simple explanation and the
simple explanation is
differences between men and women
have a partial basis in biology
if you eradicate the cultural
variability you know the environmental
variability by making the state
egalitarian all you leave are the
biological differences which maximize
it's like
dispute that how can you dispute that
it's not like it's something that
someone planned
no one was aiming at that it just that's
how it happened okay
so there is evidence we could say well
there is powerful evidence that people
have a biological nature and in built
nature and then we could also and then
you could say okay let's take that set
of data okay
the biggest difference between men and
women is in interest
and the interest dimension seems to be
people versus things
women are more interested in people and
men are more interested in things
and the difference there is about a
standard deviation it's a big difference
by by psychological standards
and it's a nice finding because
you know for a while one of the claims
was that there were fewer women in stem
discipline science technology
engineering mathematics was because
the standard deviation of male
intelligence was larger because the
curve was flatter so there were more
intellectually impaired men and more
sort of super genius men and there's a
biological rationale for that and that
one of the consequences of that was that
if you went five standard deviations out
from the mean and you needed that to be
like an expert physicist
that was so rare that the only people
who were out there were men if you know
it's like the reason that most of the
people in prison are men is because
the distribution of agreeableness is
skewed and there's way more disagreeable
men at the extreme so they all end up in
prison
that argument has not been settled but i
think you can just put it aside there's
a lot of debate about it so larry
summers brought it up at harvard and got
fired as a consequence and then a
variety of
female psychologists scoured the iq
literature and made the claim that that
finding was questionable to say the
least and maybe it is maybe it isn't but
it doesn't matter it's it's debatable
what you do find though is that if you
look at male and female performance say
in mathematics and junior higher high
school you can find a chunk of three to
four standard deviation above the mean
females and none of them go into stem
studies
and why is that it seems to be because
they don't want to
now i like that explanation because
you know if you had to have an
explanation that was palatable that
would be a good one it doesn't
it doesn't make a claim for anything
that has to do with intrinsic
differences in ability so that's kind of
nice it wipes out a whole
it depoliticizes a huge chunk of the
argument but then you could say well
maybe men and women
are
like different things because of
socialization it's like no you can't say
that because that isn't how it worked
out in scandinavia so that's the end of
that argument unless you can figure out
how those studies are wrong and like
good luck to you but i've never seen a
credible explanation
and then the next thing you could say is
yeah regardless of that men and women
should be
the same
fine
no problem you could do it
if you want to make if you want to take
say you have two kids
that are that are adopted out at birth
and they're twins
and you assess their iq and you look at
it in relationship to their
socioeconomic status one kid ends up in
a family that's poorer than 95 percent
of other families another kid ends up in
a family that's richer than 95 percent
of families so it's a big difference
the kid in the richer home will have a
15 point iq advantage so what that
basically means i've got the statistics
a little bit wrong here because i can't
translate it onto the normal
distribution but roughly speaking what
it means is that you need a three
standard deviation move in socioeconomic
status to produce a one standard
deviation move in iq what it implies is
that you can buy transformation of iq
but what it also indicates is that it's
bloody expensive it sucks and that makes
sense right you can you could imagine
that being the case if you spend enough
money you can switch something but i
would say that
the the farther you want to switch it
the more expensive it's going to get and
it's probably a curve like this a
diminishing return thing so that maybe
the first five points would be pretty
easy the next five things are getting
expensive the five after that
it's really expensive and then each
additional one point is going to cost a
lot all right fine
so what that means is that even if the
differences are biological you can shift
them
the question is two questions how much
effort are you willing to put in
and then the next question is how much
effort do you put in before it's a
tyranny
and that's the real question so we could
say
will radically transform the
socialization of boys and girls now this
has been called for before there was a
guy a psychologist
an appalling it was an appalling article
i think he was a social psychologist
which would make sense because most of
what they do is appalling and so
he proposed that the way to
decrease the radical difference in
aggression rates between men and women
was to socialize little boys like little
girls and that's been put into practice
a lot
and it will not work because what will
happen is that you'll
you might reduce the aggression of the
average guy but you're going to pop up
the aggression of the pathological guy
by such a degree that it'll completely
overwhelm whatever minor gains you make
for the typical so you're just going to
produce more guys that are so bent that
they're like hell bent for for revenge
fundamentally so
okay but you could make that case you
know like from a from a scientific or a
political perspective you could say look
it's worth investing
in the transformation of the
socialization process so we get rid of
those differences
okay the next thing you've got to ask
yourself is
why
what's the end game
now here's the end game
men and women will be represented 50 in
absolutely every occupation and there
will be zero differences in economic and
political power okay
that endgame presumes
that
that outcome has a value
you know i don't know what the value is
but some value and then the more
resources you're willing to dump in to
attain that end the more valuable you're
acting
as if it is
so you could think about it as a utopian
a utopian instinct and i'm not
complaining about
the formal proposition that that would
be a utopian end state what i'm
complaining about is or what i'm
commenting on is who says that's the
desirable outcome and how much are you
willing to risk to test it out
so because what you'll have to do
especially for things like interest is
you'll have to
punish boys for being interested in boy
things
and reward them for being interested in
girl things and punish
girls for being interested in girl
things and reward them for being
interested in boy things now i think you
could do that but
but
what if they're you know there are the
differences exist
why eradicate them do you want them
eradicated do you really want them
eradicated and you know the word
eradicated that's a rough word because
you just never know how far you're going
to have to go to eradicate things
so
all right let's see what time is it we
better have a break yes oh it's 3 30.
well there's no not much point in the
break
okay so let me yep
uh just like if i could add to your
theory with a bit of
modern neurobiology
so they started doing experiments very
recently where they
basically tried growing neurons in
different hormones and they found that
neurons grow in estrogen they're like
they grow completely differently
neurons that are grown in other things
which makes sense right if gender
differences are biological uh but the
upshot to that is
um you know it works with sort of that
theory but you have to add on is that um
you know there are men and women with
different levels of hormones it's not
uniform because sex
so when you look at you know how you're
going to raise a child
you can't just say you know it's a girl
you raise it like a girl
you have to look at
either hormone levels but because you
can't access those you have to look at
their
their gender identity
yes well that that but see that but
that's an individual relationship issue
okay so
um i've had children
and
they seem to have turned out reasonably
well
and
you know there was a variety of
differences
between them temperamentally that i
observed as they were growing up
um
it turns out
my
daughter is quite tilted towards a
feminine
temperament
because i've tested her personality
multiple times she tests all the
personalities she tests the
personalities of all her potential dates
which i think is really funny
yeah and my son has a very masculine
temperament so he's very low in
agreeableness and very high in emotional
stability and so i could see that
manifesting itself and what you do if
you have a relationship with your kids
is you adjust your interactions with
them according to who they are because
in principle you want maybe
it seems to me that in principle maybe
you want who they are to be allowed to
emerge
now i think there's some evidence that
that's what good parents do and the
reason i think that is because
when you're looking at influences on
children you can look at genetic
influences
non-shared environmental variants and
shared environmental barriers so shared
environmental variants would be if you
and i were
brother and sister in the same family
shared environmental variance would be
what was common across our upbringings
unshared environmental variants would be
what was specific to you in our family
and what was specific to me and then the
biological stuff is biological what you
almost always find in these studies is
that
non-shared environmental variance is the
most powerful after biological
predisposition depends on the trait and
so what that seems to indicate is that
the general milieu in which children is
raised has hardly any effect whatsoever
on their
trade outcomes now you can be
pessimistic or optimistic about that if
you're pessimistic you say parenting
doesn't matter and people have drawn
that conclusion there was a famous book
written about that a while back um
but if you're optimistic what you say is
no no no no no
you don't get it if you're a good parent
you eradicate the shared variance
because what you do is have an
individual relationship with each child
that takes into account their
temperamental
you know idiosyncrasies and you tailor
the environment to them and so the
shared the shared environmental variance
disappears because there is no shared
environment you know it's like
go on 10 dates and treat
each man you meet or each woman you meet
as if they were exactly the same and see
how far you get
right you're going to be one annoying
person and in all probability you're
going to get brushed off so what you
want to do is you know take the gender
into account as a broad template you
know because you need to set up your
expectations and then rapidly tailor the
hell out of that as fast as you can to
indicate that you've got some social
sophistication right well you do the
same thing with children okay so then
but that still begs the question and
this is something that you guys can
think about it's like
what do you do about the differences
do you leave them
do you encourage them that's another
thing because you could say
see the thing i one of the things i
really dislike about the social
constructionist stance is that there's
an implication that comes with it and
here's the implication
men and women are the same
okay well why is that necessary
well because that similarity is valuable
because otherwise why pursue it right
because it's valuable so people are
better off when they're the same
fine
people are worse off when they're
different ah why are they worse off when
they're different how about because
differences are not acceptable okay well
play that out if you want differences
are not acceptable well you could see
where that would lead in no time flat
you know so the mere proposition that
men and women are the same in a world
where there are differences has the
implication that the differences are
substandard and maybe even pathological
and you might say are they really is
that right is it the case that to the
degree we differ we're not mutually
complementary and not acceptable i mean
as individuals and gender um
it is
um they want to
pretend that we don't have differences
but at the same time i feel like they're
also very
um
like encouraging of
like other people expressing their
cultures and stuff like that they're
also at the same time of like saying oh
we're all the same there are no
differences they're also like oh we
should be multicultural we have a theory
about that now so we just did a study of
political correctness because we wanted
to find out i'll get to you right away
we wanted to find out if political
correctness existed right is it a
homogenous set of values
because it might not be the left claims
that the idea that political correctness
exists as a homogenous set of constructs
is a right-wing idea and that it's just
wrong that the the belief set is so
diverse you can't characterize it under
a single label it's easy to test what
you do is you get a bunch of
statements that appear to be on the
politically correct side and you can do
that relatively objectively we had a
bunch of people generate them and we
took clips from news items and all of
that so over generated a set
asked a thousand people factor analyzed
the results and we got two factors one
was sort of radical egalitarianism and
the other was language control
okay and we've already done this for
liberals and conservatives okay so the
liberals are high in openness and low in
conscientiousness particularly
orderliness
the conservatives are low in openness
and high in conscientiousness
particularly orderliness so they're
actually mirror images of one another
the the politically correct people the
first dimension which is radical
egalitarianism they're primarily
agreeable and low in conscientiousness
okay so that's different they're not
hyper liberals they're off on a
different axis okay the second
dimension
was high agreeableness
low conscientiousness is that right
local consciousness i hope that's right
doesn't exactly matter and low verbal iq
okay so
there was a reason i was telling you
that
tel ask me your question again oh um
the fact that uh a lot of left-wing
people there on one hand they try to
claim that everyone oh right good good
good okay so
the commonality so we've always we've
felt that and people make this claim
that there's something about the pc
stance that leads itself to a kind of
authoritarianism but it's weird because
a lot of the research on
authoritarianism and there's historical
reasons for that was predicated on the
claim that authoritarianism was
necessarily a right-wing phenomenon okay
so the authoritarian scale for example
which was derived by theodore adorno who
was part of a left-wing think tank um
what were they called they were in
germany i'll remember their name it was
after world war ii and they had every
reason for assuming that
authoritarianism was a right-wing
phenomenon except for all the things the
communists were doing but you know
forget about that for a moment then
there was a huge debate in the
psychological literature really till
still going on about whether
only the right can be authoritarian or
whether the left and the right can be
authoritarian that's never been sorted
out okay but what we found
so the conservatives
were high in orderliness and low in
openness okay so orderliness seems to be
the authoritarian
aspect because conscientious people like
structure and they like to compete
within structures and conscientiousness
predicts right-wing beliefs okay but it
isn't industriousness which is another
part of the conscientiousness it's
orderliness
okay
the second dimension of the
politically correct people the language
control was agreeable and orderly
and then the iq okay so this is what we
think now this is speculative but
but it's a good study and we've been
trying hard to pin this down and this
isn't my idea by the way this is my
graduate student's idea it was a very
smart idea
she thought
authoritarianism is driven by
orderliness okay fine if you're
agreeable you are authoritarian by
inclusion
and if you're disagreeable you're
authoritarian by exclusion
so the the goal is homogeneity
but the right wingers say all you
different people screw off and the left
wing says all you different people come
in here and be the same
okay so
now
i think the way that that pertains to
your question is that i think the left
wing manages that weirdly paradoxical
viewpoint
by assuming that whatever differences
exist are cultural and so they can just
be
in time they can just be ameliorated
that's what it looks like to me i mean
it really does seem
paradoxical right
that you can you can be for
egalitarianism and celebrate differences
and you see this turns out very weirdly
so i've met so many people
well let me give you an example of what
happened so do you guys know who ian
herzia lee is yes
how many of you know
okay now
good good look she's quite the damn
character now ayan hershey elite i would
look her up i think she's a real hero
that woman she is tough as a bloody boot
she came from ethiopia she escaped from
an arranged marriage and she was in a
very hierarchical
you know authoritarian muslim family so
she had to run and she did and so that
was tough man to get away from that you
know she had to forfeit her familial
ties and all of that and then she went
to the netherlands to study
and
the netherlands shocked her and she she
said a couple of things that shocked her
that i thought were so cool the first
thing that shocked her was that she was
at a bus stop and there was a little
digital sign there there that said when
the bus was coming and then the bus came
like right at the time it was supposed
to she couldn't believe that that could
actually happen and if you think about
how many things have to be going right
for that to happen you know that her
detection of that miracle was accurate
and the fact that we just assumed that
that's just shows you how well things
work
and the second thing she was amazed
about was
that if you asked a policeman they would
help you because in most countries
policemen are
like they're just an extension of thug
right they don't get paid anything so
all the money they make is from you and
they're not there to maintain order or
to help you they're there as a control
arm of the state
anyway she went and got a liberal arts
education
and
she
was very taken by the idea of individual
sovereignty roughly speaking and the
enlightenment so she turned into a
really pro-enlightenment person and then
she got into the dutch parliament
and she also had
there was a bit of a scandal about that
which i won't go into
she also had a relationship i think it
was just a friendship with this guy
named van gogh who was actually a
descendant of van gaal and he made this
video
that had naked women in it with verses
of the quran written on them and it was
very very very very controversial
because these were anti-female verses at
least that's what he thought and so
he got stabbed and what happened was the
guy that stabbed him was a muslim
extremist took
the the note that explained why he was
being killed and stabbed it into him
okay so that was nasty so ayan herzia
ali eventually she her life was in
danger to such a degree
and a variety of things happened in
holland that she had to move to the
united states with bodyguards and so she
lives there now
and
she's an outspoken
critic
of patriarchal oppression in the best
sense like she experienced it it was
terrible like she got away from it and
you know
and and in a really remarkable and
honorable and admirable way
and i read ayan herzeali before she was
politically controversial except in
holland well last year brandeis
university offered her a
honorary phd
and the students
set up a petition
saying that she couldn't
be granted that phd because of her
objection to
to muslim to radical muslim faith and
they disinvited her so that's a good
example of this weird paradox it's like
i read ayan herzeali and i thought jesus
if anybody ever had a case to make about
the oppressive nature of the patriarchy
like as someone who had personally
experienced it it's like
you read her story and you think oh yeah
there's no doubt about that and so then
she makes this
immensely complex and sophisticated case
for the individual rights of women
and
brandeis invites her to give her an
honorary degree and then they rescind it
because the students complain about her
and that was the radical left students
who were complaining i just thought
i thought first of all that's amazing
it's i just can't believe that happened
and second i couldn't believe that that
pathetic university came and withdrew
their their invitation to her she's a
tough cookie man and i think she's a
real hero
and that was irrelevant like some
students were upset they made a petition
so like who cares about ion hersey ali
and her
you know
amazing journey i've noticed that like
if i if i bring up
um
infringements on women's rights that
contradict like the liberal narrative of
like the straight white white male
hatred that's impressive maybe you know
maybe like it's like some poor people
you know in a very like you know uh
muslim majority country oppressing women
if i bring that up it's i feel like a
lot of times they get threatened by it
because like it contradicts their their
main narrative which is like the
oppressive white meal
well the pro you know generally the
problem the problem with a set of
axiomatic presuppositions is that you'll
find situations where they conflict i
can give you another example
so
um
that's definitely one you know so you
say well
diverse ethnicity and diverse cultural
background is a plus but then you think
oh well some of these practices look
like they're not exactly commensurate
with what we would regard as appropriate
okay so we have a problem there
here's another problem
so of of the same sort and i'm using
this as an example just to show you how
axiomatic systems produce internal
conflicts so um
the access to abortion has become
increasingly universal in western
countries although it's backtracked a
lot in the u.s over the last 10 years
for a variety of reasons
but there's a there's a weird
consequence of that
and one of the consequences is that
female fetuses get aborted at a much
higher rate than male fetuses worldwide
okay so what do you do about that
like is that acceptable or not because
if it's not
well then then there's a problem because
you know you have to face
you have to face
what do you have to face exactly
that there is an ethical question when
it comes to abortion because how if
abortion is not wrong how could
selective abortion possibly be not wrong
like maybe you could maybe come up with
an explanation for that but i've never
seen a credible one but that's just a
good example of how
if you use an axiomatic system
there's inevitably the case where the
axioms collide and it's sort of like
am i free to offend you with my speech
two axioms freedom of speech and and you
know integrity of person at what point
am i inciting aggression
so oh and it's also the case i think
where the why the horus osiris thing is
absolutely necessary so you could think
of osiris as a set of axiomatic moral
presuppositions like a list of rules
like the ten commandments
the problem is is that not only do the
rules get out of date over time you know
um
we don't worry very much about coveting
our neighbors goat for example you know
so so they become obsolete across time
but worse than that
there are situations where if you apply
both they conflict
so then what do you do well the answer
is you pay attention you know you pay
attention because you have to mediate
between the conflict well horus is also
the thing that mediates between the
conflicts and that's partly why
in the mesopotamian story you have
marduk and one of the things that marduk
demands when he's elevated to the
highest position which is you know so
that makes him ruler of all the gods and
you can think about those as you know
integral motivational forces or
principles he gets the tablet of
destinies
which means that what he represents is
the thing that makes the decisions and
that's often the decision between two
rigid approaches to right and wrong
and so you say
a chaotic approach to right and wrong
that's a catastrophe
and then you say well you replace that
with a system of rules
which is better but the system of rules
has two potential problems one is it
will age
and the other is that it produces
internal conflicts so then you need a
third principle
and the third principle to me seems to
be what the egyptians represented with
horus
and then you get into a you get into a
communicative dialogue between the horus
factor which is attention and the
culture
like this they mutually inform one
another and that keeps things structured
but also flexible enough to adapt across
time and then the system has to build in
recognition for that and that's where i
think the idea of individual rights
comes from it's like
you have an individual right because
you are a necessary player in the
process that keeps the forces of order
and chaos balanced across time and if
you're shut down or oppressed or not
allowed to speak
then the society denies itself that
corrective action
and the corrective micro corrections say
and then what happens is it gets more
and more and more rigid and more
tyrannical because people have to
falsify their experience to adhere to it
and then the bloody thing collapses
precipitously and that's what happened
with the soviet union
so you either make micro corrections
or you accumulate
error
and collapse and i think that so i've
looked at that psychologically and i
think
i think the way that people do that in
their own life is that they adjust their
own psyches
with micro corrections and then they
communicate about freely
and then that's enough to keep the
society dynamic but you have to let
people speak
so
that's why that you know freedom of
speech is a critical characteristic of
modern democratic states it's like it
doesn't matter what the person says it's
irrelevant whether they're right or
wrong it doesn't matter if they're
offensive it's not the point the point
is is that you have to let the chatter
emerge
so that you can sort the wheat from the
chaff
and if you suppress it then the error
correction mechanism goes away
um they've actually talked about donald
trump in
terms of political fracking
oh there's absolutely no doubt about
that i was looking today they just fired
a professor at marquette university yeah
okay
was it marquette in it was marquette
okay so what this guy did he's he's a
self-proclaimed conservative he has a
blog and
he
he uh
a ta was teaching a course where the
idea of gay marriage came up and the
student approached her afterwards and
said that that he had opposed gay
marriage and she said there wasn't
something like there wasn't going to be
any discussion of that in her class and
and
he recorded that and then that was
released and then
this character
wrote a blog and criticized the graduate
student for for not letting this guy
speak okay so far
so
you can read the blog that caused quite
a lot of trouble and eventually he got
fired okay so fine whatever i read
opinions on both sides you know that the
conservative critics said ah this is
just another case of someone being
hounded out of his job and the people on
the left said
he misused his position of authority to
go after this graduate student in public
and that wasn't due process and so it
wasn't his opinions that got him fired
it was his failure to observe university
regulation so fine whatever something
can be said on both sides of the
argument but then i looked at the
comments
well
twenty to one
they were this is why we're voting for
trump
yeah
yeah and i do believe that because trump
is disagreeable
and that means he'll say anything
he'll shoot off his mouth he'll say
anything and the thing is people don't
care what he says
what they care about is that he'll say
anything that's what they're going after
and they definitely see that as a
a gesture of hostility
towards the pc left they say that
so the problem is is you know
when you
extremism always calls the devils out of
the closet so if you move too far to the
left in any way you call the demons of
the right out and vice versa it's a
psychological principle it happens
within people's character
so
you know i i was privy to a
a line of
communication between a bunch of people
who who weren't poor you know white
trash
so to speak
you know the stereotypical trump
supporter these people were well
ensconced in the middle and upper middle
class and virtually and they were almost
all men virtually to a man they said
something like the system is so rotten
we're going to bring it down and i
thought really that's what you guys are
thinking you're that
reactively angry
and
you know if you're in a marriage and
then
you refuse to let your partner speak for
decades
you bloody bit well better be careful
when they decide to speak because you're
going to come home one day i used to
tell this children's story in this class
about a guy who
there's a little dragon in the house and
it's ignored by everyone and it
eventually runs away with the house and
so mr bixby who's the head of the
household the guy who's off working
comes home and his house is gone so he's
surprised the house is gone he asks the
neighbors where it went and you know the
basic story is something like well there
was something not going on so good in
that house and people ignored it got
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger finally it ran away with his
house well that happens to people all
the time they come home and their
partner has packed up taken the kids and
left it's like i didn't see that coming
it's like
c is the right word you know did you
have a million warnings
likely you know now now and then someone
gets screwed they're married to someone
who's psychopathic and you know
they're just doomed from the start but
generally it's not that it's the
accumulation of a million unsolved unhad
arguments and finally it explodes
and that's what happens when you
suppress free speech
the the for the reason you support free
speech is not because people it's not
even because it isn't because people
have a right to be heard that isn't it
exactly
it's that people have a right to be
stupid and ignorant and you need to
listen to them because then you know
where the stupid and ignorant people are
and you can you can have a discussion
with them instead they feel oppressed
and they go hide and then
that's not good that is not good
because they can say well we're
oppressed and that justifies their
stupidity and ignorance and it's like
they are oppressed whether that
justifies their stupidity and ignorance
is a whole different question but you
don't stop
destructive morons from talking ever
because the fact that you don't let them
talk doesn't mean that what they think
goes away plus you don't have a chance
to confront them
so
anyways
we'll we'll finish up on this next week
but here's the central idea
people have an ethical responsibility to
embody horus let's say because we can
take it out of the religious context
that way because like none of you guys
are ancient egypt worshipers right so
it's it's irrelevant from uh from a
cultural perspective but what the
egyptians carefully laid out was the
idea that
it's the it's the force that pays
attention especially to corruption and
evil that revivifies the state at its
own risk because of course horus loses
nine in the conflict it's there's never
any indication that this is easy you put
yourself at risk to do it
but the risk you avoid by doing it is
the ultimate degeneration of everything
into hell
so there's a risk to be taken to say
what you think
but it's a moral obligation and the
consequence of not doing it is that the
system deteriorates into hell and you
might say well is that
prove it
okay fine it's proved that's what
happened in the communist countries and
the documentation is it's so clear that
the formal rat there are many who are
formed were formerly radical lefties and
communists in france who have written a
book saying that it's true
so you know when you completely convert
reconvert the converted you have to
think well maybe there's some power to
that and solzhenitsyn's basic point
continually was
there's no way the soviet system could
have kept its talents in people if they
would have refused to lie and the lies
were always
you'll face this in the workplace you
wait and see it's going to come because
what will happen is
someone will come they'll be a bit of a
bully and they'll come to you and
they'll say well how about if you do
this work and you'll think hey really
that's your work and it's not kosher
that you're giving it to me but you
won't say anything you'll say okay
because you'll think well i don't want
to cause any trouble it's like hey no
problem but the next time that work
comes your way you can just remember
that you facilitated that process
because you didn't say anything to begin
with and when you get your 10 000 piece
of work and you're crushed right over
and you think why is the system so
goddamn corrupt you might remember that
you opened the door this much with your
first response and people do that all
the time it's a it's a minor
falsification of their experience and
one of the things i've learned about
that and you can think about this as a
good guide
if you're resentful about something
you're either immature
or you have something to say
if you're immature well then you should
grow up you know
but if you have something to say
you should say it
because
the pathology of the system has
manifested itself within the domain of
your experience it's right there in
front of you and it's only gone
it's only tilted just this micro tilt
you know off kilter and you might think
well i'm not going to make a fuss out of
because of that because it's so little
it's like
there's a book called ordinary
germans
ordinary man sorry it's a famous book
and it's a story about this troupe of
german policemen who were taken to
poland once the germans had marched
through
and they were bourgeois guys all raised
before hitler came to power just
i think you could just think about them
as middle-class suburbanites that's
basically who they were you know
average comes
okay they ended up by taking naked women
out into the field who were pregnant
shooting them in the back of the head
and so you think well how does that
happen and the answer is one tiny little
step at a time and this is well
documented in the book because the guy
who wrote the book was curious it's like
well how do you take ordinary people who
in principle are no worse or better than
anyone else and get them to commit
unbearable atrocities and then he walks
you through it it's like
they're asked to do x and they say okay
and then they're asked to do x plus one
and they say okay and they're asked to
do x plus two and they say okay and by
the time they're at x plus a hundred
things are looking pretty dismal and
it's getting hard to step back you know
and then
then the descent instead of being like
this goes like this and there's no
bottom there's absolutely no bottom
and so the trick is to nip it in the bud
and the way you do that is by
by being very very careful about what
you say and then when something is not
going right and you know it
you have to say something and you might
say well maybe i'll get fired
and i would say how the hell do you know
that's not the best thing that could
happen to you
you know because if you're in a system
that will not take your feedback when
you're being reasonable then you're in a
nascent tyranny and it could be easily
the best thing that ever happened to you
to get out of there before you're
crushed completely
so
so you know the most sophisticated
political philosophers of the 20th
century in my estimation came to the
conclusion that the reason that horrific
genocidal crimes take place is because
ordinary people lie
and that's
a radical conclusion
but
a
how could it be any different
i mean
if people start
if people let the system deteriorate by
not opposing it when it does
how can things end up any different than
now
then i would say well
that maps perfectly onto classical
religious ideas so let's we could say
talk about horus we could talk about uh
mardic
but the idea of logos that's underlying
christianity is exactly the same thing
because what logos basically means is
truthful communication that's what it
means and that's the thing that in the
judeo-christian tradition identifies
people with
the part of god that creates order out
of chaos it's it's it's laid out clearly
in the theology and the other part that
goes along with that and this is where
the story
as the story rolls to a conclusion is
that if you
manifest the logos you end up being
crucified and reborn but
in principle
that can happen in small enough ways so
that it doesn't actually have to happen
you know because if you learn something
you know if something if something's
bothering you
it's bothering you you think it through
what inevitably happens is that as you
think it through and incorporate the
information
old presuppositions are forced to die
and that's painful it's hard on people
because you have to re-examine your
principles
you know at a high resolution level or a
broad level
part of you is going to die especially
if you need a radical change but maybe
if you let the part die and revivify
then the whole doesn't have to die and i
think that that scales it's like
it works within the personality
but it also works within the
personalities organized into a
hierarchical state if you don't allow
that
death and resurrection process to occur
and you suppress it enough the whole
state has to die
and then you know the probability that
that's going to take everyone with it is
very very high
so that seems like a bad long-term
outcome and well